Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
als ich losfahren wollte, ging das E-Land hiermit los.
Äh, Moment, das...
Das ist doch gar nicht.
Ja.
Also, es ging erst mal, bevor ich losgefahren bin,
ging es erst mal damit los.
Erst mal so, das geht noch.
Ich meine, ich wohne nicht weit vom...
Ähm...
Bahnhof weg, also ich kann dann auch 5 Minuten später laufen
und das ist alles nicht so wild, ja.
Ich mein...
Ich hab mich mal wieder aufgeregt drüber, ja,
dass die Ficker wieder am Werk sind.
Okay, ich bin dann...
Ich gib's zu, ich schlag da teilweise etwas über die Strenge, ja.
Aber...
Das regt mich...
...sehr auf.
Das regt mich immer extrem auf, ich raste wirklich aus.
Zumindest ging es weiter, das ging weiter, das E-Land.
So.
Dann hab ich mich aufgelassen, wie sehr ich die Bahn verachte und so.
Ihr seht schon, es wird immer mehr.
Jetzt sind wir schon bei 20 Minuten, am Anfang waren es 10 Minuten.
Irgendwann haben sie aufgehört, die App zu aktualisieren.
Und es ging dann einfach nicht weiter.
Zumindest...
Also ich hätte eigentlich da sein sollen,
ja, man sieht's ja hier, Frankfurt Süd, 8.58 Uhr,
und ich war um 10 Uhr, kurz nach 10 Uhr am Südbahnhof.
Das heißt, ich hab für eine Strecke,
die normalerweise, sag mal, eine halbe Stunde braucht,
äh...
...quasi eineinhalb Stunden gebraucht.
Wenn man mal den Ursprungsabfahrtsding sieht.
Ja.
Ja, und das Beste war, der Zug, der soll ja eigentlich...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich es überhaupt gescreenshotted hab.
Der Zug fährt eigentlich weiter zum Flughafen.
Und da waren auch viele Leute mit Koffer im Flughafen,
äh, im, in der ähnlichen Flugzeug, in der Bahn.
Und auf einmal war es so,
die Bahn sagt durch, weil wir so große Verspätungen haben,
fahren wir nicht weiter als Frankfurt Süd.
Und ich wette mit euch, die ganzen Leute haben sich dann auch gedacht,
die Ficker sind wieder am Werk.
So.
Zumindest, die haben da gar nicht drauf geantwortet,
was ich aber auch verstehen kann, was soll man denn da drauf antworten.
Haben die mich heute wieder aufgeregt, Alter.
Ich hab so unglaublich großen Hass und Verachtung
gegenüber diesem Laden, das ist unglaublich.
Also, ich, das ist jetzt keine Übertreibung,
ich mein das wirklich ernst, ja.
Jetzt denken die Leute wieder, Max flippt wieder aus,
und so, nee, ich mein das wirklich ernst.
Also, ich, also, ich, ich mein das ernst.
Und ich muss auch sagen, ähm, ich hab jetzt vergessen,
was ich sagen wollte.
Keine Ahnung.
Ähm, was wollte ich denn sagen?
Das ist ja eine geile Kombination, Alter.
Montana Black Alpha 4 Games und dann hinten drauf Money Boy.
Oh, oh, Leute.
Ich hab eine neue Nachricht von der Corona-Warn-App.
Oh, oh. Oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
Increased Risk.
Was ist das denn?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Moment.
Exposures on one day with increased risk.
On 17. Mai, letzte Woche, Dienstag.
Das würde ich jetzt ja schon merken, oder?
Warum kriege ich heute die Nachricht am 17. Mai?
Was, ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Ich glaube, ich aninstall das Ding jetzt auch, Alter.
Äh, das ist ja mal komplett useless.
Ah, der Typ hat heute erst gemeldet.
Der Typ hat heute erst gemeldet.
Updated to day 20.18.
Also, Leute, Pleading Edge-Informationen.
Um was geht's?
Ich hab ein increased risk in der Corona-App angeblich.
Der hat heute erst gemeldet.
Letzte Woche ist er Zug gefahren anscheinend, okay.
Ja, gut.
Ja, dann hätte ich es wahrscheinlich schon längst gemerkt, oder?
Wenn ich es gehabt hätte jetzt.
Nick, danke für den Sub.
Danke für den Sub, Leute, falls irgendwer es sonst noch gesagt hat.
Ich muss mich gerade über die Bahn aufregen.
Vielleicht hing das Fax auch eine Weile.
Okay, jetzt kriegen wir...
Moment, ich kriege noch Empfehlungen, Guidelines.
Also, Particular Attention, dass ich mich an die Hygiene-Rules halte.
Naja, das ist jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen spät, oder?
Zehn Tage danach.
If possible, please go home.
Wisst ihr was, ich screenshotte mir das.
Und nächste Woche, wenn ich auf die Arbeit fahre,
zeige ich das dann.
Leute, sorry.
Corona-App sagt, ich soll heimgehen.
So, und dann soll ich alerted sein für Typical Symptoms.
Please get tested.
Nee, ich schiebe mir heute garantiert nicht so ein Ding in die Nase.
Ich meine, das ist zehn Tage danach jetzt schon.
Ich soll mich impfen lassen.
Und ich kann mich... Ich kann die Nummer...
Moment, wer steckt denn dahinter?
Ich darf 116 117 anrufen.
Wer ist das?
Der Patientenservice.
Und dort soll ich dann in der Warteschlange
die Zwei drücken im Hauptmenü.
Und danach die Eins.
Alter, wir sind...
Oh, das ist ja aber...
Ja, gut, das ist der ärztliche Bereitschaftsdienst.
Das ist normal, dass dieser Kram schlechte Bewertungen hat.
Da sind beispielsweise auch die Zahnärzte,
die Notfalldings haben, die keinen Bock haben, dich zu behandeln.
Nee, nee, das ist klar, dass die schlechte Bewertungen haben.
Zeig mal.
Komm, wir hacken mal eine Runde.
Also...
Okay, eigentlich ist es nicht lustig.
Eigentlich ist es eher traurig, dass das so kacke ist,
obwohl so viel Geld reingesteckt wird.
Aber wer weiß, in welchen Taschen letztendlich die ganze Kohle landet?
Ich bin auch überzeugt davon, Leute, dass das bei der Bahn...
Also das Hauptproblem.
Wisst ihr was?
Meiner Meinung nach, das Hauptproblem ist,
dass das bei der Bahn...
Wisst ihr was? Meiner Meinung nach, das Hauptproblem ist,
warum, also nicht, warum ich die Bahn hasse, das meine ich so.
Wie gesagt, es gibt ja immer die Leute,
jetzt weiß ich, was ich sagen wollte, die sagen, Max,
du übertreibst Toxydank für den Zahn.
Stimmt, doch, ich meine das ernst.
Ich hasse sie abgrundtief.
Nicht die einzelnen Leute, sondern dieses Gesamtkonstrukt,
was wir haben als Bahn.
Ich habe so unglaubliche Verachtung gegenüber diesem Laden.
Das könnt ihr euch nicht vorstellen.
Ja, und das ist ernst gemeint, das ist wirklich keine Übertreibung.
Mir war gar nicht klar, bis zu dem Zeitpunkt,
bis vor ein paar Jahren, als das mit der Bahn...
mich so über ein gewisses Level genervt hat,
mir war gar nicht klar,
dass man etwas so sehr hassen kann,
wie ich die Bahn hasse.
Das muss wahrscheinlich ungefähr ähnlich sein zu...
Ich weiß nicht, mir fällt... Ich kann das schlecht verkleiden.
Ich habe in meinem Leben noch nie jemand so gehasst mit die Bahn.
Das ist keine Übertreibung.
Natürlich ist die Bahn keine Person.
Das Gesamtkonstrukt, egal wie,
Leute, die mich in der Schule abgefuckt haben,
da hatte ich auch Leute, die konnte ich nicht leiden,
aber das beruhte meistens auf Gegenseitigkeit,
oder es gibt Kollegen auf der Arbeit,
die kann ich nicht leiden.
Es gibt ein paar Leute, die kann ich alle nicht ab,
aber ich würde bei keinem so weit gehen.
Es gibt ein paar Mädels, wo ich sage,
die haben mich komplett verarscht
oder absichtlich fertig machen wollen.
Alles möglich, aber ich hasse diese Leute nicht in diesem Sinn.
Ich denke mir, blödes Sau oder so was, und dann ist gut,
vor allem, weil das meist schon ein paar Jahre her ist,
und man sich da wieder beruhigt.
Aber die Bahn, ich hasse die Bahn.
Also, ich hasse die Bahn so sehr, dass wenn...
Wenn die Bahn eine Person wäre,
und die Person würde beerdigt werden,
ich würde auf die Beerdigung gehen,
nur, um auf das Grab zu treten und drauf zu spucken.
So sehr hasse ich die Bahn.
Ich habe einen abgrundtiefen...
Ja...
Hass auf diesen Laden mittlerweile,
den ich auch wahrscheinlich nie wieder loswerden werde.
Und das haben sie sich verdient.
Das haben sie sich regelmäßig verdient, die letzten...
Äh, 15 Jahre über, nee, länger.
Die letzten 20 Jahre über.
Juliens Blog wurde dafür eingegangen. Warum?
Ich darf sagen, dass ich die Bahn hasse. Wo ist das Problem?
Ich hasse die Bahn. Das ist ja keine...
Das ist ja noch nicht mal eine Beleidigung.
Das ist ja das Schöne daran.
Was hat er denn gesagt?
Übertreibst... Ja, das war, was ich jetzt gesagt habe.
Okay, Leute, ich hasse auch C++, aber...
Im Ernst, ich hasse C++ deutlich weniger als die Bahn.
Ja, so ungefähr, Alter.
Ja, gut, das sind natürlich Sprüche, die würde ich auch nicht bringen.
An der Stelle sowas.
Ja, das ist natürlich bescheuert.
Das ist dann weniger das Problem, dass man die Bahn geflamt hat,
sondern eher, dass man vielleicht irgendwas...
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das verfassungsfeindlich nennt
oder was gesetzeswidriges gesagt hat,
wo im Zweifelsfall sogar Knast draufsteht.
Keine Ahnung, das mache ich ja nicht, das würde ich auch nicht vergleichen damit.
Was die Bahn bekommt jetzt noch weniger als vorher.
Also, okay, ich sage euch jetzt mal was.
Wisst ihr, was ich denke, was wirklich das größte Problem ist?
Bei der Bahn.
Ich rede jetzt, mir ist klar, dass es prinzipiell viele Probleme hat.
Also von Personalmangel bis Strecken abgebaut die letzten Jahre,
mir ist klar, dass es viele Probleme hat.
Aber das hauptsächliche Problem...
Warum ist mein Chrom braun? Weil es Chromium ist und nicht Chrom.
Das hauptsächliche Problem, was ich bei der Bahn sehe, ist Folgendes.
Dass die Führungsebene der Bahn absolut kein persönliches Interesse daran hat,
die Bahn in die Richtung zu bringen, dass es quasi pro Fahrgäste ist.
Und nicht pro sich selbst Geld einstecken.
Also, ich sehe in der Bahnführung und in der Entscheidung,
was da getroffen wird, kein persönliches Interesse daran,
dort an dieser Situation was zu ändern.
Vor allem, solange man mit jährlichem, ja, politischer Wille vielleicht auch noch,
aber wichtig ist mir erst mal, dass die Bahn selbst,
in dem Falle sind sie Chef von der Bahn,
einen persönlichen Antrieb hätten, da was dran zu ändern.
Wollen sie nicht. Weil man kommt ohne Probleme durch.
Man ist dick buddy mit den politischen Entscheidungsträgern.
Teilweise sind die Leute direkt aus der Politik in die Bahn.
Also, man ist da ganz dicke.
Und man kommt damit hin, dass man sich jährlich hinstellt,
dass man die Leute anlügt,
beispielsweise mit komplett zu Recht gefakten Verfügbarkeitsstatistiken.
Ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, die Bahn faked ihre Statistiken so krass.
Und trotzdem sind die schlechter als die vorgegebenen Ziele.
Also, die machen quasi die Ziele selbst
und erfüllen die Ziele noch nicht mal, faken dann die Statistiken.
Und sie sind immer noch schlechter.
Also, ihr könnt euch mal vorstellen,
was die Wirklichkeit wäre, wenn die Ziele jemand anderes vorgeben würden,
wenn die Statistiken nicht gefaked wären.
Noch viel schlechter wird das Ganze aussehen.
Deswegen deckt sich die Statistik ja auch nicht mit dem,
was man als Bahnkunde so empfindet, wenn man die öfters benutzt.
Ich glaube, der Böhmermann hat letztens auch ein Bahnvideo gemacht.
So, das ist das hauptsächliche Problem.
Du kannst dich dort als Bahnchef hinstellen,
Bullshit erzählen, und es hat absolut keine Konsequenzen.
Was sollen die Leute machen?
Ja, ich kenne das vom Kriesel, das Video, klar.
Die Leute haben, du kannst da nichts machen.
Was die Schweizer Bahn besser macht,
ehrlich gesagt weiß ich nicht genau, was die Schweizer Bahn besser macht.
Ich vermute mal, oder was die japanische Bahn besser macht.
Ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung, aber ich würde jetzt mal raten.
Ich rate jetzt mal, ja.
Also ich, wie gesagt, ja, übrigens, mein Zug,
da wurden die letzten Halte heute auch ausfallen lassen,
weil das so große Verspätung hat.
Das ist auch ein komplettes Unding.
Kannst du nicht die Leute, die über den fucking Flughafen fahren wollen,
mit dem Zug aussteigen lassen in Frankfurt Süd?
Das ist ein Flugzeug.
Ich habe übrigens nicht von Hass gesprochen auf Twitter,
auch wenn es vielleicht Hass sprech ist für einige.
Ich habe darüber gesprochen auf Twitter,
dass ich die Bahn verabscheue.
Das ist auch so, da kann keiner was dagegen sagen.
Ich kann verabscheuen, wen ich will.
Wenn ich mal vermuten müsste, was der Unterschied ist zur Schweizer Bahn,
ich denke mal, dass dort die Bahn nicht umgebaut wurde
die letzten 30 Jahre oder so, in irgendwas,
was profitabel sein soll und irgendwann mal in die Börse gehen soll.
Ich vermute mal, dass dort nicht kleine,
nicht so sehr befahrene Strecken am Arsch der Welt abgebaut wurden.
Teilweise durch nichts ersetzt wurden oder im Zweifelsfall
durch irgendwelche Private, die sie übernehmen sollten,
mittlerweile auch nicht mehr fahren.
Dass Bahnhöfe entschlackt werden,
dass es teilweise gar keine Bahnhöfe gibt,
dass es noch nicht mal mehr Warteräume gibt an kleineren Bahnhöfen,
dass du nicht mal scheißen gehen kannst am Bahnhof.
Ihr kennt mal ein Video zum Hanauer Bahnhof,
wo es noch nicht mal ein Klo gab.
Ich glaube, dass die Schweizer Bahn hauptsächlich dafür da ist,
um den Schweizer einen Infrastrukturservice zu bieten.
Wofür die Schweizer wahrscheinlich auch relativ viel Kohle abdrücken.
Das ist die Bahn bei uns nicht dafür da.
Die Bahn soll uns keinen Infrastrukturservice liefern.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mal,
was die Bahn aktuell überhaupt für einen Service liefern soll.
Es ist ja auch egal, weil es hat keine Konsequenzen,
weil ich meine, die verfehlen seit Jahren ihre eigene,
selbst vorgegebene, zurecht gefakte Statistik.
Und es ist egal.
So.
Das ist doch scheißegal,
ob man einzelne Sachen miteinander vergleichen kann.
Es spricht doch nichts...
Ich meine, Leute, wir sind das...
Nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle,
das viertreichste Land der Welt,
wenn es um...
Wohlgemerkt, muss man sagen.
Wenn es um Wirtschafts...
Was genau geht?
Ist es Bruttoinland? Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Wir sind quasi vierttritt oder viertgrößte...
Wirtschafts...
Nation der Welt.
Es ist vollkommen egal, was die anderen machen.
Wenn wir sehen, dass es bei den anderen besser funktioniert,
sollte man sich vielleicht überlegen, ob man das nicht auch so macht.
Oder sich überlegen, wie können wir es bei uns verbessern?
Allein diese Sache mit, wie können wir es bei uns verbessern,
hört ja im Keim auf.
Weil es kein persönliches Interesse gibt,
der Bahnführer und den Kram weiter zu verfolgen.
Solange man durchkommt mit Statistiken, faken,
unter den Erwartungen zurückbleiben, und trotzdem passiert nix.
Und dann der Planke Hohn für alle Leute,
die sich regelmäßig diesen Shit geben müssen.
Bei der Bahn...
Mit dem 9-Euro-Ticket wird sich höchstens was daran ändern,
dass noch mehr Leute im Zug sitzen,
dass noch mehr Penner aus Frankfurt im Zug fahren.
An sich finde ich das 9-Euro-Ticket eine super Geschichte.
Ich finde, dass an sich sowas eigentlich immer sein müsste.
Aber das Problem ist, dass die Bahn
jetzt schon den normalen Verkehr absolut maßlos überfordert ist.
Und wenn jetzt noch mehr Leute dazukommen,
die wahrscheinlich nicht alle im Berufsverkehr fahren würden,
ist das Ding komplett hinüber.
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute mit einem 9-Euro-Ticket
werden damit genau einmal Bahn fahren.
Zumindest einmal, wo es in die Hose geht.
Und dann nie mehr in diesen scheiß Zug einsteigen.
Ja, ich gehe auch davon aus,
dass dieses Ticket viele Leute abschrecken wird.
Also, ich stelle mir das so vor.
Ich stelle mir das so vor.
Sagen wir mal, die Oma...
Ach, das mit nach Sylt fahren ist, glaube ich, das kleinste Problem.
Die Oma kauft sich ihr 9-Euro-Ticket und denkt sich so,
morgens um halb neun,
ach, fahren wir doch mal von Hanau nach Frankfurt.
Und gehen da was essen oder so.
Oder ich treffe mich da mit Erna.
Und wir gehen dann da irgendwie ins Café auf der Zeil.
Auf der Zeil ist ein scheiß Ort, um ins Café zu gehen.
Wir gehen beispielsweise am Mainufer mal ins Café
und trinken da ein bisschen Kaffee.
Denkt sich die Oma morgens um 8.30 Uhr oder um neun.
Dann setzt sich die Oma in den Zug
und wäre normalerweise nach einer halben Stunde am Hauptbahnhof.
So.
Und nachdem die Oma dann zwei Stunden später wieder nach Hause kommt,
weil sie nicht erreicht hat das Ziel,
fertig mit den Nerven ist,
zwischendurch gedacht hat,
sie kommt nicht mehr lebend aus dem Zug raus,
wird die Oma nie wieder in einen Zug einsteigen mit ihrem 9-Euro-Ticket.
Ich glaube, das 9-Euro-Ticket wird viele Leute abschrecken.
Und ich glaube, heute Morgen haben die Leute geweint im Zug.
Baumeister, ja...
Lest mal in Twitter.
Mir geht es nicht um die Leute, die bei der Bahn arbeiten.
Das ist überhaupt nicht das Problem.
Und auch nicht die Leute,
die das bei mir auf Twitter manchmal von der Bahn abkriegen.
Die können ja da nichts für.
Die werden nie wieder mit dem Zug fahren.
Okay, gut.
Hätten wir das jetzt auch abgefaggelt, ja?
Hat ja keinen Sinn.
Leute, ich hatte heute eine im Zug, die hat geheult.
Weil die Bahn zu spät war.
Und wir waren ja nicht einfach nur zu spät.
Wir waren ja nicht einfach nur zu spät.
Das ging von 10 Minuten am Anfang bis 1,5 Stunden.
Eine 28-Minuten-Fahrt hat 1,5 Stunden.
Aha, okay, nicht 1,5 Stunden.
1,5 Stunden, 1 Stunde 15 gebraucht.
Ja, ich auch.
Das stimmt nicht.
Ich fahre schon seit einer ganzen Weile nicht mehr jeden Tag.
Mittlerweile noch einmal die Woche.
Und sogar da kriegen sie es nicht hin.
Es ist ausgeschlossen, dass du 15 Jahre mit der Bahn fährst
und die Bahn auch gut findest.
Und wenn doch, glaube ich dir nicht,
dass du mit der Bahn fährst.
Kommst du am Hauptbahnhof vorbei?
Was, am Frankfurter oder am Hanauer?
Äh, ja.
Frankfurt.
Meist Südbahnhof, manchmal auch Hauptbahnhof.
Das ist ja das Problem.
Ja, das ist ja das Problem.
Du hast ja recht, natürlich.
Ja, gebe ich dir recht.
Und wisst ihr, was richtig Planke hohen ist?
Ähm, dass noch vor nicht allzu langer Zeit
darüber diskutiert wurde, dass man Leuten verbieten soll,
mit dem Auto in die Stadt zu fahren.
Ja, wie stellt ihr euch das denn vor?
Wollt ihr das einfach alle Leute da nicht mal arbeiten können?
Oder einkaufen können?
Oder irgendwas Sinnvolles machen können
und nicht den ganzen Tag für brauchen?
Das klappt nicht.
Im Fahrrad klappt das auch nur bedingt.
Und ich laufe ja mittlerweile auch viel,
gerade wegen P-Pro-Fat.
Und ja, aber man kann manche Sachen nur beschränkt fahren.
Und beschränkt laufen.
Manchmal bleibt ja nichts anderes übrig,
wie beispielsweise mal nach Frankfurt zu fahren.
Und ich fahre nicht nebenbei nach Frankfurt
mit dem Fahrrad oder laufe da zweieinhalb Stunden hin.
Das ist tatsächlich das Problem.
Zumindest, es ist absolut Planke hohen.
Ich sehe das ähnlich.
Das wird ohne Bahn nicht funktionieren.
Das Problem ist, dass wir das mit Bahn
in diesem Zustand und so, wie sich das entwickelt,
auch nicht anders hinbekommen.
Und, also, es ist, was ich sagen wollte,
es ist Planke hohen,
dass noch nicht vor allzu langer Zeit darüber diskutiert wurde,
Leute zu verbieten,
mit dem Auto in die Innenstadt zu fahren.
Also, wenn die Leute Randale wollen,
dann können sie das mit so was kriegen.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
dann ist tatsächlich mal die Kacke am Dampfen.
Ich meine, das ist in Deutschland ja schon anders
als beispielsweise in Frankreich.
In Frankreich, die zünden ja quasi wegen jedem Blödsinn
Deutschland ist ja im Prinzip, da kann die Welt untergehen
und, ja, eigentlich
macht da keiner was so richtig.
Aber dann ist, glaube ich,
wirklich die Kacke am Dampfen,
wenn man das wirklich durchsetzen würde,
dass die Leute nicht mehr
in die Stadt vernüften.
Und deswegen, glaube ich auch,
dass diese ganzen Aktionen, die es aktuell gibt,
ihr habt ja vielleicht mitbekommen,
dass Leute sich auf Zebrastreifen legen
an Autobahnen, Abfahrten legen und so was.
Ich frag mich übrigens, wer das bezahlt.
Ob da wirklich was passiert.
Ich glaube, dass es so ist.
Ich sag immer, ich glaube,
ich kann die Leute nicht reingucken.
Also ich bin mir auch gar nicht sicher,
wie diese Aktivistengruppen heißen aktuell,
die das machen. Ich glaube, es ist nicht
Fridays for Future, es sind irgendwelche anderen Typen.
Ist auch egal. Habt ihr wahrscheinlich schon
irgendwo gelesen, dass es aktuell relativ oft Leute gibt,
die sich auf Fußgängerüberwege legen
und sich wegziehen lassen und so was in der Richtung.
Ich glaube, dass die Leute das wirklich gut meinen.
Die, die das machen.
Also ich glaube, also gut meinen,
in Form von, die denken, sie tun
der Menschheit,
der Umwelt, der Welt, der Menschheit
was Gutes. Das glaube ich wirklich,
dass die davon überzeugt sind.
Das Problem, was ich mit solchen Aktionen sehe,
ist, es wird niemand dazu bringen,
zum Nachdenken.
Also stellt euch mal vor,
ihr seid eh schon abgefuckt
im Berufsverkehr morgens.
Irgendein Typ legt sich
auf den
Fußgängerüberweg
und du bist bei By the Way
und dann erzählt dir einer, du sollst gefällig
mit dem Zug fahren. Das ist die Auswahl zwischen
Pest und Cholera. So, zumindest
du bist im Berufsverkehr, du bist eh schon abgefuckt
und dann legen die sich
auf den Fußgängerüberweg.
Wird irgendeiner
von den Leuten,
die dort in diesen Autos noch
noch mehr abgefuckt werden
mal wirklich kritisch darüber
nachdenken,
was die Punkte Umweltverschmutzung
und
Konsumgüterverbrauch
und Wegwerf
ja,
wie nennen wir das, Kulturen, was auch immer,
was es noch gibt. Da wird auch keiner
drüber nachdenken.
Da wird auch keiner sich
über sowas drüber Gedanken machen
und sagen, ach ja,
ach ja, jetzt wo ich mich
mal so richtig drüber aufgeregt habe,
dass da ein Typ auf dem Zebrastreifen gelegen hat,
jetzt baue ich mir, glaube ich mal
ein paar Solarpanels aufs Dach.
Das wird genau zu einem führen,
dass die Leute sagen, und jetzt erst
recht. Das ist ungefähr so,
oh, der Stream hat geleckt,
ich werde gleich gecancelt,
man weiß ja nie,
wann,
das ist ungefähr so,
wie wenn du
richtig krass überzeugter Veganer bist,
der nicht einfach nur Veganer ist,
sondern Leute bekehren möchte.
Und er erzählt dann allen Leuten,
was für Unmenschen sie sind, wenn sie Fleisch essen.
Der hat ja gar nicht mal Unrecht
objektiv gesehen.
Der hat ja gar nicht mal Unrecht.
Aber was bei den Leuten dann passieren wird,
ist, die sagen, alter,
nur um diesen Typ jetzt so richtig abzufucken,
gehe ich jetzt
erst mal auf
irgendeinen Online-Shop und bestelle mir
ein Kilo Rinderfleisch.
Einfach nur um den Typ abzufucken.
Und genau das Gleiche passiert auch,
wenn Moins einer
auf dem Fußgänger über mich liegt,
um quasi die Autofahrer zum Nachdenken
anzuregen,
über das, was ich gerade gesagt habe,
das Einzige, was passieren wird,
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es in irgendeiner Art
und Weise einen positiven Ausgang hat,
wird dazu führen,
dass der Typ sagt, und jetzt erst recht.
Nicht etwa, dass die sagen,
na ja, okay.
Wenn ich es mir so recht überlege,
da ist ja schon was dran.
Da habe ich mir ja nie Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Aber jetzt, weil der Typ auf dem
Fußgänger über mich gelegen hat,
jetzt mache ich mir mal Gedanken drüber
und stelle fest, so viel
Zeug verbrauchen
und immer wegschmeißen und Plastik ins Meer
und so, das ist doch nicht gut.
Ich habe jetzt nur Gedanken, weil einer
auf dem Fußgänger über mich gelegen hat.
Das ist Schwachsinn, will keiner machen.
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Und ich glaube, dass tatsächlich die Leute,
die das machen, wirklich die besten Absichten haben.
Sehr log, danke für den Sub.
Ich glaube, die haben die besten Absichten.
Ich glaube, die wollen wirklich die Welt besser machen.
Aber das Einzige,
das Einzige, wozu das führt,
ist, dass sie sich im Endeffekt das nächste Mal
einen noch fetteren SUV kaufen.
Und nicht etwa,
weil sie das eigentlich wollen,
sondern nur, um den Typ abzufacken,
der auf dem Zebrastreifen gelegen hat.
Ihr könnt euch gar nicht vorstellen,
was so trotz Reaktion, was das für
Emotionen in den Leuten
auslöst.
Das macht total bescheuerte Sachen
auf einmal für die Leute
eine plausible
Entscheidung.
Und deswegen, ich glaube nicht,
dass das irgendwas bringt,
diese Sorte der Proteste.
Dabei wäre es ganz einfach,
wenn man nicht will, dass die Leute im Auto fahren.
Du musst unsere Bahn verbessern.
Das ist das, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte.
Das ist das, warum ich auf dieses Thema
gekommen bin. Du musst unseren öffentlichen
Nahverkehr verbessern. Das heißt,
du musst dort fahren können,
wo du jetzt nicht fahren kannst, weil sie die Strecken
und Weichen und alles abgebaut haben in den letzten Jahren,
um das Ganze zu billiger zu machen.
Du brauchst mehr Personal.
Das geht nicht von heute auf morgen.
Du brauchst mehr Züge. Du brauchst mehr Strecken.
Du brauchst generell mehr Geld.
Du brauchst den Willen dahinter, das zu machen.
Du brauchst nicht
utopisch teure Fahrpreise
und lange Fahrdauern.
Wenn ich nach Dresden fahre, das ist doppelt so lang
und doppelt so teuer, wie wenn ich im Auto fahre
und doppelt so stressig.
Und ich bin mir sicher,
ich kann es mir zumindest nicht
gegenteilig vorstellen, wenn das der Fall ist,
dass du weißt,
ich kann mich an den Bahnsteig stellen,
dort
in den Zug einsteigen,
innerhalb der nächsten Viertel halben Stunde.
Viertelstunde wäre eigentlich das beste.
Und komm
dann auch in Frankfurt an.
Ohne, dass ich danach
am liebsten
irgendwelche Leute aufs Maul hauen will,
also entspannt an,
dann werden viele Leute
freiwillig darauf verzichten,
so oft im Auto zu fahren.
Du hast immer noch Leute,
die werden sagen, jawoll,
ich habe hier mal einen krass getunten BMW,
ich will unbedingt mit dem fahren.
Okay, das wird es immer geben, da kannst du nichts dagegen machen.
Aber viele Leute,
wenn die die Alternative haben,
es ist nicht so, dass sie sagen, ich muss unbedingt mit dem Auto fahren.
Wenn es eine Alternative gibt,
die
zumindest in einem Belang
wirklich deutlich besser ist,
dann werden das viele Leute machen.
Und wenn es in mehreren Belangen deutlich besser ist,
werden es noch viel mehr Leute machen.
Die haben das sogar zurückgebaut
in die letzten Jahre über.
Danke für den Sub.
Ich habe heute Leute mal was lustiges zu erzählen.
Ich habe heute das, glaube ich,
das Kokona X Video gesehen,
aller Zeiten.
Das Video war so hardcore Kokona,
da wusste ich,
ich wusste gar nicht,
außer, dass ich mein komplettes Hirn
gefüllt war,
mit diesem Emote,
konnte ich ja nichts anderes sehen.
Und zwar,
Moment, ich muss mal den Chat durch scrollen.
Und zwar, wisst ihr was,
der Bahnhof, jetzt ist er vorbei, Leute.
Jetzt ist er vorbei.
Wisst ihr, was das für ein Video war?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich es finde.
Moment, ich muss mal,
Leute, ich muss mal kurz in meine
YouTube-History gucken.
Das war ein Video,
da hat jemand auf seinem
Grundstück Hornissen gehabt.
Und jetzt ratet mal,
was der gemacht hat,
um die Hornissen loszuwerden.
Denkt an die, die,
also die Ami-mäßigste Art,
die euch überhaupt einfällt.
Ich muss das Video.
Ich muss das Video mal kurz suchen.
Sorry.
Sprengstoff, korrekt.
Der hat die in die Luft gesprengt.
Moment, ich muss das mal kurz raus.
Da war ich echt irritiert.
Der hat die gesprengt.
Moment, wo ist das?
Ja, okay, okay.
Das wurde mir heute empfohlen
auf YouTube, ich weiß nicht warum.
Wasp Nest vs. M80.
Das Video ist schon alt
und auf 4 zu 3 aufgenommen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das Video ist schon alt
und auf 4 zu 3 aufgenommen.
Das Video ist schon alt und auf 4 zu 3 aufgenommen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Vielleicht ist er auch ein Engländer.
Mehr Ami geht nicht.
Mehr Kikona geht nicht.
Keiner geht nicht
Achtung
Es ist so, Alter, die Habis waren, Alter, ich weiß es nicht
Warum hat er einen Sprengstoff am Stiel, um das Nest in die Luft zu sprengen?
Die Habis haben echt schon ein bisschen Schaden in der Richtung, Alter
Es geht noch weiter, es geht noch weiter, da hat er zwei Nest, da oben am Haus hat er auch noch eins
Dem hätte ich gegönnt, dass sie ihm aufs Kopf fällen
Ich glaube, das ist es, und es ist weg
Alter, guck dir das an
Die Habis, Alter
Unglaublich, oder? Jetzt freuen sie sich aber noch
Oh Mann
Also das war wirklich lange Zeit, mehr als Keiner in einem Video geht nicht
Also es hätte jetzt bloß noch getopft werden können, wenn sie den Rest mit irgendeinem Assault Rifle runtergeschossen hätten oder sowas
Ja gut, also komm, dass man die nicht, das erwarte ich da gar nicht, dass man da nicht zusammenhangt
Vielleicht waren es auch Bienen, ich weiß es gar nicht, vielleicht waren es auch Bienen
Ne, Ne, Äh, Wespen
Aber müsst ihr zugeben, oder? Das war äußerst Kokona das Video
Ich musste halt wirklich, ich hab das auf dem Rückweg im Zug geguckt, ich musste wirklich lachen
Wahrscheinlich haben die Leute gedacht, was ist mit dem der bloß, ja?
Ich hab mir das angeguckt, ich musste echt lachen, ich hab mir das am Kopf gekriegt, Alter die Habis wieder
Ah Mann, Alter Wahnsinn, unglaublich
Auch sehr Kokona, trau ich mich das aufzumachen
Oh, ach das ist der Typ, Moment, vor dem haben wir schon mal ein paar Sachen geguckt
Oh ne, oder? Elektroschockt der jetzt die Wespen?
Ja das bringt es auch richtig
Ja super, der hätte das auch abfackeln können
Erstmal das Haus abfackeln, ja
Oh Mann
Vor allem, vor allem Ami-Holzhäuser können nicht brennen
Das ist ja bekannt
Ne, wir gucken jetzt keine Schädlingsbekämpfung an
Und wir gucken, und wir gucken ob wir das machen können
Ne, wir gucken jetzt keine Schädlingsbekämpfung an und wir gucken, und wir gucken auch nicht
Old Mobile, komm, scheiß drauf
Und wir gucken auch keine Teppichreinigungs wieder an
Was? Man will Kakerlaken beseitigen und sprengt dabei halben Garten in die Luft, Brasilien
Ok komm, 54 Sekunden
By the way, woher weiß der Dude eigentlich was der machen will?
Ihr meint, es könnte ja alles mögliche sein
Ich seh, ich seh, ich seh ein Loch im Boden und, ok
Die armen, die armen Hunde von dem
Der, der erschreckt, der traut sich seines Lebens nicht mehr in Garten
Sag mal, wie bescheuert sind die Leute eigentlich und lassen ihre Hunde auch noch dabei sitzen
Sind die nicht, ist es, ist es, ist es nicht geil
Irgendwie in Sinn gekommen, dass das auch nach hinten losgehen könnte
Ok
Was zum
Ok, ok, nur dass ich das richtig, nur dass ich das richtig verstehe
Der hat da Benzin reingeschüttet und will jetzt das anzünden mit einem, mit einem äh
Alter, wie heißen die Dinger?
Alter mein Hirn, alter setzt aus, MonkaS
Matchsticks, wie heißt denn der Kram auch?
Streichholz, alter
Es ist so schlimm teilweise, es ist so schlimm, es ist so schlimm
Alter, es ist so schlimm teilweise, es ist so schlimm
Dass ich
Den Krempel auf Englisch weiß
Aber auf Deutsch nicht, ja
Jetzt
Wobei heißt es überhaupt Matchstick?
Matches, also es heißt Matches, Streich, oder Match, Streichholzer
Matches heißt, es heißt gar nicht Matchstick, es heißt Matches
Ok
Streichholzer
Also der, der will wirklich das da jetzt reinschmeißen
Hat er mal was davon gehört, dass man beispielsweise auch irgendwie so eine, so eine, so eine Zündschnur oder sowas
Wobei es glaube ich schwierig ist Benzin überhaupt anzuzünden, wenn es da drinne ist, weil da ist ja kein Sauerstoff
Egal, wir gucken es jetzt einfach
Achtung, Achtung, Alter, was, oh man, was ein Dämpf
Alter, was ein Vollidio
Oh man, vor allem der Hund da hinten, guck mal, der, der ist, der, der scheißt sich gerade in die Hose
Guck mal
Alter, was ein Volldämpf man
Unglaublich
Ok, das ist auch ein Video, das, das hätte ich mir ohne Probleme im, im, im Land der Konas vorstellen können
Kann sein, ich weiß nur nicht ob es Match ist oder Matchstick
Ich, ich hätte auch instinktiv gesagt Match, Matchstick, aber ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob es Matchstick heißt, Streichholz
Gucken wir mal, Leo Dickt
Streichholz, Match, nee einfach nur Match
Das Schwarzpulver Streichholz
Oh man, also manche Leute, die kannst du, da ist echt nichts mehr zu retten
Also, also was hab ich jetzt gemacht, ich hab eine Stunde über die Bahn geflamt und wir haben uns bescheuerte Leute auf YouTube anguckt, exzellent, exzellent
Was, sag mal, ich weiß, dass, ich kenn dich vom Chat, ich weiß, dass es kein Chebat ist bei dir, wo man dann, das ist nämlich der Trick, den es aktuell gibt, also diesen, diesen, diesen Streamer-Verarschtrick
Dass man die Leute irgendwelche Sachen aussprechen lässt, die anders, sich komplett anders lesen als ausgesprochen, sie dann klingen
Ich kann jetzt kein Beispiel bringen, weil, ok, also was soll ich aussprechen, tschechisches Streichholz-Schächelchen
Ja
Und jetzt
Weiter
Das war's, ok
Äh, aber wo ist der, wo ist der Witz dabei, CackWade
Also, dachte, da kommt jetzt irgendwas noch
Das ist wie, es gibt ja, es gibt ja so viele, so viele Zungenbrecher, da gibt's doch im Englischen, die haben noch diese Geschichte mit, äh, three switch, switches, swatch
Oh mein, was, three switches, switches
Three switches, watch, three, oh fuck, Alter, das kann ich nicht
Das ist
Ja gut, das kenn ich, ja, dass die Leute mit Brat herringen, wisst ihr, ja, das verwende ich schon, wisst ihr welcher Name, das weiß ich, weil ich, weil ich auf der Arbeit mehrere Leute kenne mit dem Vornamen
Wisst ihr, welcher Vorname für Amis unglaublich verwirrend und, und, äh, schwierig ist
Ich weiß, was das ist, was das bedeuten soll, vor allem nicht verlit speaked, Matthias, nein, Uwe, Uwe ist unglaublich schwierig für die
U, U, UV, UW, die können Uwe, die können kein Uwe auch sprengen, gescheit, die kriegen das nicht in, Uwe macht die fertig, ich bin der Uwe, ich bin auch dabei, genau
UV, die meisten sagen irgendwie sowas wie UV, oder UV, ja, die kriegen das gar nicht hin, also, Max hat man das wirklich einfach, Max geht eigentlich überall, ja
Egal, Spanisch, Italienisch, Englisch, Deutsch, wahrscheinlich können das auch ohne Probleme, Skandinavia, das alle, also, Max ist überhaupt kein Problem, das kriegen sie alle gebacken
Ich meine, die Italiener, die Italiener sollten am wenigsten Probleme mit haben, das ist ja ursprünglich was irgendwas Römisches
Wer weiß aus dem Kopf, wie der Kladiator hieß, also, der Kladiator aus dem Film
Scheiße, jetzt hab ich's vergessen, wie rum, jaja, Maximus, ähm, Maximus Decimus Meridius, oder irgendwie so
Also, das ist ja was Römisches, ja
Eugen sprengen, ja, ja gut, das kann ich ja noch irgendwie verstehen, aber Uwe haben so richtige Probleme mit
Maximil, ja, gut
Ja, bisschen, bisschen cringe ist es schon, aber es ist, es ist überall so, wisst ihr, wisst ihr was auch richtig cringe sein muss?
Wir hatten ja die letzten Jahre über auf der Arbeit einige mit Russ, ich sag absichtlich nicht Russen, weil das ein, ja, zur aktuellen Zeit viele Diskussionen immer nach sich zieht
Ob's denn jetzt wirklich Russen waren oder irgendwie drumherum, ich sag nur, dass es, ich sag absichtlich nicht Russen, weil das ein, ja, zur aktuellen Zeit viele Diskussionen immer nach sich zieht
Ob's denn jetzt wirklich Russen waren oder irgendwie drumherum, ich sag Leute mit sehr russischen Namen hatten wir, und ich weiß, dass es nicht alles Russen waren, wir hatten sogar Leute mal aus der Ukraine
Aber zumindest, ich sag mal Leute mit ganz vielen Leuten mit russischen Namen, mindestens fünf Russen, anführungsweise, mit den letzten Jahren
Was da auch ganz schlimm sein muss ist, bald die Aussprache der Namen, also, ich mein, die wissen, dass sie gemeint sind, aber die müssen, glaub ich, wenn Deutsche ihre Namen aussprechen, oftmals hart cringen
Weil die, weil unsere Betonung komplett off ist
Ja, wir sagen zum Beispiel Evgeni oder sowas, das spricht man ganz anders aus, ich glaub die eigentliche Betonung ist auf dem zweiten E, das ist ja irgendwie sowas wie Evgeni
Eigentlich, aber ich glaub die cringen wirklich richtig hart, wenn wir den Kram aussprechen, aber sie wissen zum Glück, wer gemeint ist
Ja, vor allem, also, die Leute, die hier sind, ja, schon seit, keine Ahnung, zehn Jahren und hier ganz normal arbeiten, versteh ich auch nicht
Viele haben damit ja auch nix am Hut, was da so abgeht
Ja, hatten wir, hatten wir, also wir hatten, das war überlegen, also wir hatten ein Evgeni, einen Sergei, einen Alexei, einen Vladislav, einen
Oh, wie ist der andere
Den krieg ich nicht mal zusammen
Keine Ahnung, also jetzt ist auch egal, also wir hatten, wir hatten viele und es arbeiten auch viele Russen in Deutschland IT, technisch
Okay, das ist der naheliegendste Witz, der nur irgendwie geht, ja
Wobei der heute schon ganz schön grenzwertig ist, ja
Mitri hatten wir glaube ich keine, ist auch egal, who cares, Infinity Ward, was sagen sie denn
Leute, warum ist es eigentlich Modern 2 Warfare, warum steht da Modern Warfare 2 und hier oben steht Modern 2 Warfare
Es ist so, also ich persönlich finde es komplette Bankrotterklärung
Jeglicher, das Ende, nicht dass Call of Duty durch großartige Kreativität geklenzt hat in den letzten Jahren über
Aber das ist wirklich das Ende jeglicher Kreativität, der Aufguss vor dem Aufguss, die Fortsetzung quasi des Reboots, es ist
Gut, es ist eh so ein Ding, ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich da nicht mal ein Video zu machen sollte, also nicht in dem Fall zu, sondern allgemein
Aber ich habe mich zu diesem Thema schon so oft geäußert, zwar noch nie zusammen in einem Video, aber in den letzten Jahren über verteilt
Dass gerade so die Mainstream Games, die es aktuell gibt, das hat für mich jegliche Magie irgendwie verloren
Das ist heute so, das fühlt sich alles an, ich rede nicht von allen Games, die es gibt, sondern hauptsächlich von den aktuellen AAA Games
Und sogar da gibt es ab und zu noch ein paar gute, aber ein Großteil davon fühlt sich so, wie soll man sagen, am Reißbrett entworfen
Ohne jegliches Engagement auf Herstellerseite, einfach nur das möglichst Mindeste abgeliefert, dass keinen irgendwie zu sehr ärgert
Oder, keine Ahnung, zu sehr herausfordert, dass was keinen irgendwie zu sehr verwirrt, das muss möglichst irgendwie alle Leute ansprechen, aber auch wieder keinen
Also die meisten AAA Games sind heute einfach so langweilige
Als hätte quasi die Marketing Abteilung, so die Leute, die sich das ausdenken, als hätten die quasi so ein Puzzle aus, die haben 20 Teile
Und daraus dürfen sie sich jetzt 5 Teile aussuchen für ein Game und dann wird das irgendwie zusammengesteckt und dann sagen sie, ja sowas können wir mal wieder machen
Ich meine, Cyberpunk kann man wenigstens das nicht vorwerfen
Also ich gehe davon aus, dass die Leute bei Cyberpunk tatsächlich mit sehr viel Einsatz dabei waren
Und auch wirklich ein gutes Game machen wollten und auch große Ambitionen hatten und es ist halt in die Hose gegangen
Aber man kann Cyberpunk nicht vorwerfen, das wäre irgendwie so ein Retorten-Game, mach mal hier Teil 85 oder nehm mal da ein bisschen Türme erobern
Nehm mal da ein bisschen aufgesetzten Skillbaum und nehm mal da ein bisschen 0815 auto generated open world und dann mach mal Game
Und dann verkaufen wir das und machen krass viel Influencer-Werbung, die das alles geil finden müssen
Und das kann man Cyberpunk nicht nachsagen, also Cyberpunk hat halt den Griff ins Klo gemacht mit ihrem Produkt am Ende
Aber nicht, weil es ein so liebloses AAA Produkt war
Das würde ich sogar sagen, es war eines der Ausnahmen die letzten Jahre über, es war aber trotzdem Griff ins Klo
Ja das kommt auch noch dazu, übrigens habt ihr gelesen, wollt ihr mal cacken ne Runde?
Wollt ihr ne Runde cacken, also
Wo ist es?
Ich bin heute eh schon geladen, ja
Twitter
Warum ist da manchmal ein Knopf und manchmal nicht?
Okay, ich sag's euch
Weil ich nicht weiter runter scrollen kann
Ich sag's euch
Hazardzone wird eingestellt
Netter.net
Okay
Weil ihr es seid
Battlefield.com
Alles klar, netter
Sehr gut
Punkt wird ja erstklassig
Irgendwas was mir der Chat gerade empfohlen hat
Achso, ich muss da drauf klicken oder was?
Achso, das ist ja schon wieder Interface of Doom gewesen
Die haben gepostet, dass Hazardzone eingestellt wird
Das hab ich heute gelesen, ich finde aber den Post nicht
Die stellen Hazardzone ein
Und dazu hab ich mir gedacht, warum habt ihr den Kram überhaupt erst entwickelt?
Gut, ich weiß warum sie den Kram entwickelt haben
Weil Hazardzone wahrscheinlich ursprünglich der Kern Spielmodus sein sollte
Weil auch der einzige Spielmodus, wo die Spezialisten Sinn machen
So, aber Hazardzone wird eingestellt
Okay, sorry, sorry, nicht eingestellt
Wir sind ja im Jahr 2022
Wo keiner mehr gerade im Marketing Bereich irgendwelche normalen Aussagen treffen kann
Nein, nein, nein Hazardzone ist winding down
Sorry Leute, es wird nicht eingestellt
It's winding down
Aber eine Frage, wir haben eine Geschäftsstelle in Amerika
Solange die nicht irgendwelche Hornissennester in Luft sprengen mit Sprengstoff ist doch alles okay
Sind per VPN Tunnel mit uns verbunden
Die sind zu klein um einen eigenen Artiller zu haben
Und hat einen engagierten Netzwerkbetreuer
Wir haben neulich festgestellt, dass der bei ihnen einen neuen Router eingebaut hat
Welcher an unserer Firewall vorbei für aber im selben Netz hängt
Na ja, was ist denn das für eine Firewall
Wenn du an der einfach vorbei routen kannst
Was ist das für ein Netz?
Warum ist das Ding nicht das Gateway
Und ohne das Gateway zu verwenden, kommst du nirgends wohin
Das ist ja bescheuert
Ich sag mit bescheuert, ich meine nicht, dass du das falsch konfiguriert hast
Weil du hast damit wahrscheinlich nichts zu tun
Weil wenn der sich einfach da dran vorbei routen kann
Dann kann auch irgendjemand einfach ein Rechner anstöpseln an irgendeinem Port
Und zweifelsfall, sogar wenn er die Rechte hat, den Rechner nehmen, der schon da ist
Und dort einfach sowohl Netz als auch Gateway und sonst was ändern und sich auch überall vorbei tun
Also ne Firewall, die du einfach mit irgendwelchen IP-Settings umgehen kannst, ist ziemlich schlecht platziert
Man kann nicht sagen, dass die Firewall schlecht eingerichtet ist, weil die Firewall kann ja nichts dafür
Wenn es noch ein zweites Gateway gibt, das an ihr vorbei geht
Aber die Netzwerkstruktur ist vielleicht nicht so die Schlauste
Aber natürlich ist das ein Risiko
Ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich nicht umsonst eine Firewall, da stehen mit den entsprechenden Regeln
Und wenn die Amis jetzt komplett da dran vorbei können, ist es natürlich blöd, weil ich vermute mal
Dass die Firewall eigentlich davor schützen soll, dass wenn man, ich denk mal, dass die auf euch zugreifen
Wenn da auf interne Systeme zugegriffen werden soll, dass eben sichergestellt ist, dass das nur über, sagen wir mal
Port 443 oder, keine Ahnung, was auch immer, ja möglich ist
Und wenn es da noch einen zweiten Netzwerkweg gibt, ist die erste Frage überhaupt, warum gibt es den?
Und dann das nächste Weg ist, das muss zugemacht werden und du musst über die Firewall gehen
Weil sobald du ein zweites Gateway hast, was quasi internes Server erreichen kann
Gibt es ja absolut keinen Sinn, dass man eine Firewall stehen hat
Das eine hat jetzt nicht zwangsläufig was mit dem anderen zu tun
Ja es funktioniert, natürlich funktioniert es, es funktioniert aber deutlich mehr als die wahrscheinlich haben wollen
Also immer mehr Cloud-Provider z.B. Twitch, Launch und unterstützen mittlerweile Server
Ach, haben die es mittlerweile auch hingekriegt?
Ich hab letztens erst gesucht nach einem Pass-Anbieter
Coolen Leute nennen das ja so
Serverless ist eigentlich schon wieder out, man sagt aktuell eher, wobei Serverless sei das nicht out
Serverless sagt man nur, aber ganz cool, wenn man sagt Fast heutzutage, Function as a Service
Also auch Server, also Fast ist nicht gleich Serverless, Fast ist ein Teil von Serverless
Serverless heißt ja im Endeffekt nur, dass du keinen eigenen Server betreibst
Sondern jemand anderes, also Serverless bedeutet, jemand anderes betreibt den Server für dich
Und du musst dich nicht dafür interessieren, wie der das macht
Also Serverless ist quasi Cloud, so wie es eigentlich sein soll
Der Name ist halt richtig bescheuert, weil Serverless sich so anhört wie, als gibt es keinen Server mehr
Das ist bescheuert, am Ende liefert es immer noch irgendeinen Web-Server aus
Also wenn du jetzt Serverless, keine Ahnung, du machst in Azure irgendeine Serverless Funktion
Und bastelst da dein.NET hin, irgendwo ist was, das nimmt deine Web-Request an und schickt eine Response zurück
Und zwar, das schickt HTTP zurück, das ist ein Web-Server, der das macht
In welcher Art auch immer, und irgendwo drauf muss das laufen
Also irgendwo steht was, wo ein Web-Server drauf läuft und der liefert dann euren Kram aus
Nur dass es halt nicht euer Server ist
Also es ist im Endeffekt etwas misleading, dass das ganze Serverless heißt
Es ist quasi eine Hosted Runtime, ja aber worauf läuft denn eine Hosted Runtime?
Wahrscheinlich nicht auf dem Fax von der Sekretärin, sondern wahrscheinlich auf einem Server
Ja, das hat Vorteile, das hat Vorteile und Nachteile
Okay, da muss ich jetzt mal ein bisschen ausholen, aber ich glaube das ist eine interessante Frage
Also, und ich, wohlgemerkt, ich sag jetzt nicht, dass das hier vollständig ist, sondern das erste was mir einfällt
Also, Vorteile
Alter, ich hab schon ganz trockenen Hals wieder, weil ich mich so aufgeregt hab vorhin und jetzt die ganze Zeit am schwitzen bin
So, ähm, ich muss mich jetzt erstmal ein bisschen beruhigen wieder und normal reden
Also, Vorteile von Serverless, also wir machen mal so ein Vorteil nach Nachteile-Ding
Ein riesengroßer Vorteil ist, du musst dich nicht um die Infrastruktur kümmern
Weiterer Vorteil ist, du bekommst Skalieren in der Regel umsonst dabei
Mit umsonst dabei meine ich nicht, dass es kostenlos ist, sondern dass du meistens nicht sonderlich viel dafür machen musst
Also, sagen wir mal du hast, ähm, eine Funktion, so, also, sagen wir mal du hast, du hast eine Funktion irgendwo in der Cloud
Ja, wenn du die aufrufst, du machst Curl, ja, äh, geile fastdomain.com, slash, ähm, keqw
So, und du hast da eine, eine Funktion, die keqw zurückliefert
per HTTP-Request, weil das ja die sinnvollste Funktion ist überhaupt
Dann kannst du damit einen Client abfackeln oder zwei Millionen
Das ist erstmal egal
Und je nachdem, was du für Limits gesetzt hast in deinem Cloud, äh, in deinem Cloud-Konto und was du für ein Guthaben hast
kannst du nahezu beliebig deine Serverless Functions skalieren
Das ist damit mehr oder weniger umsonst
Du hast keine Server, die du irgendwie im Hintergrund anfahren musst
Ich mein, du kannst das alles selbst bauen, das ist keine Frage
In mehreren Schritten, ja
Die nächste, etwas niedrigere Schicht wäre, dass du irgendwie ein Managed Kubernetes-Gedöns hast
Da musst du dich aber immer noch selbst ums Deployment, ums Management des Clusters kümmern, ums Updaten des
Wobei, ums Updaten, je nach Management eher nicht
Aber zumindest ums Deployen, ums Skalieren, du musst dir Regeln überlegen
Okay, du musst dir Loadbalancer-Setups überlegen
Okay, du hast natürlich dann mehr Einfluss drauf
So, die nächste Stufe, das zu bauen wäre natürlich, okay, du kannst auch sagen, ich miete mir einfach
2-3 V-Server
Und skaliere die dann anhand der Auslastung von meinem Loadbalancer, anhand den Connections von den Loadbalancern
Skaliere ich das mit irgendeinem Skript hoch
Das funktioniert auch, mehr oder weniger schnell, mehr oder weniger gut
Du kannst dann beispielsweise einen fetten Loadbalancer davor stellen und sagst, okay, wenn das Ding
Bei 1000 Connections ist, dann mache ich halt noch eine zweite VM an
Und wenn das bei 5000 ist, dann mache ich halt noch eine dritte VM an
Da muss die VM halt erstmal hochgefahren werden, professioniert werden, deployed werden
Kannst du alles automatisieren
Ja, keine Frage, das geht
Haben wir hier, haben wir CAC WSS-Service, haben wir das ja genauso in der Lite-Variante selbst gebaut
Mit einem 10 Zeilen Bash-Skript hinterm Loadbalancer, der den Kram dann deployed
Da musst du dich aber schon um vieles kümmern, was du bei Serverless Functions nicht hast
So, also, dass du Skalieren umsonst mit dabei kriegst, ist eines, finde ich, der der großen Pluspunkte
So, nächster Pluspunkt ist, du musst dir auch keine Gedanken um die ganze Infrastruktur machen, weil das ist ähnlich
Machen wir mal eins gleich, also musst dir keine Gedanken um die Infrastruktur machen
Du deploysst quasi einfach nach der Anleitung des jeweiligen Hosters oder Anbieters deine Funktion
Wie auch immer das funktioniert, ist ja nach Anbieter ein bisschen unterschiedlich
Das einfachste, was ich bisher gesehen habe, aber der Anbieter hat nicht, Toni
Der Anbieter hat, glaube ich, nicht so große, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das noch gibt
Der Anbieter hat nicht so großen Zuspruch gefunden
Das habe ich mal bei Hacker News gelesen vor einer Weile
Das ist die einfachste Variante, die ich gesehen habe bisher, wie einer Serverless Functions gemacht hat
Du machst hier einen Account, du hast einen Editor auf der Webseite
Da schreibst du drei Zeilen JavaScript, drückst deploy und deine Funktion ist oben
Also so einfach habe ich das noch nirgendwo gesehen
By the way, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es den Anbieter noch gibt
Oder er ist auch nicht der billigste
Also das ist nicht so eingeschlagen
Ich habe da vor einer Weile was drüber gelesen und jetzt mal nach einem halben Jahr wieder geguckt
Und das ist nicht so gut angekommen, aber das ist die einfachste Variante, die ich bisher je gesehen habe
So, Digital Ocean kenne ich nicht, habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt
Müssen wir vielleicht mal machen
Ich muss die Musik ausmachen, ich finde die Musik nicht
Heute holst du die Musik
Da
Und ich habe irgendwie jetzt noch Mario angemacht
Ah, zu viel
Kirby
Please
Wo ist die Musik
Alles klar
So, okay
Weiter im Text, ich blick nicht mehr durch
Ansonsten, wenn du dir das anguckst bei Azure
Ich glaube Hetzner hat sowas noch nicht
Du kannst es auch ohne Probleme selbst hosten, aber da musste ich wieder drum drum
Nein, ich habe meinen USB noch nicht, ich habe ihn noch gar nicht bestellt
Wenn du es über Azure machst, dann musst du
Du musst es halt deployen
Im Endeffekt nach dem jeweiligen Tutorial von deinem Anbieter
Ja, irgendeinen N-File hinterlegen
Oder manche erlauben es ja, komplette Docker-Container-Server das laufen zu lassen
Dann kannst du laufen lassen, drinne was du willst
In der Regel haben so klassische
Was klassische kann man nicht sagen
In der Regel ist es so, dass die Anbieter für Functions
Meistens so zwei, drei, vier Sprachen unterstützen
Meistens ist es JavaScript
Manche machen TypeScript noch dabei
Manche machen noch Go dabei
Ruby habe ich auch schon gesehen
.NET fällt mir jetzt bloß Azure ein
Die.NET unterstützen direkt als Functions
AWS, was macht denn AWS, Leute?
Wisst ihr das aus dem Kopf?
JavaScript, Go?
Keine Ahnung
Was sind Serverless Functions?
Serverless Functions ist im Endeffekt
Du programmierst ein Snippet, Code
Ja, was passieren soll, mit einem Request, der reinkommt
Also, weiß aber warum sage ich ein Snippet, Code
Du programmierst eine Funktion, die bekommt als Input
In der Regel ein Request-Objekt
Nämlich der Web-Request, der reingeht
Und dann kannst du eine Antwort zurückschicken
Also quasi so ähnlich was
Wie in deinem Controller bei einer Web-Anwendung
Für einen Get-Request oder Post-Request
Nur, dass du eine Funktion hast und sonst nichts
Und diese Funktion kannst du dann deployen
Ja gut, das musst du, das musst du
Routing musst du dann in deinem
Serverless GUI machen
Oder vielleicht, vielleicht, ich weiß es nicht
Vielleicht gibt es mittlerweile auch
Bei, ich glaube, da habe ich sogar letztens ein Tutorial gesehen
Du kannst das Routing wahrscheinlich auch über irgendeine Config-Datei machen
Das habe ich glaube ich letztens bei Netlify oder so gesehen
Da kannst du es über irgendwelche Config-Dateien machen, ja
Es gibt auch die Möglichkeit mit Gateway, alles möglich, ist egal
Zumindest, der Sinn davon ist
Du programmierst eine Funktion
Der bekommt ein Request-Objekt als Input
Und du schickst eine Antwort raus
Mehr machst du nicht
Das deploys du und das läuft
Du kannst dir auch automatisch ausführen, was man anbietet
Aber in der Regel ist es so
Du bekommst ein Request geschickt, eine Antwort ist dann da drauf
Es gibt einige Probleme damit
Zum Beispiel, dass das passt jetzt hier wieder ein bisschen
Dass es lange Zeit so war
Dass Cloud-Funktionen, wenn sie nicht benutzt wurden
Eine gewisse Zeit gepresst wurden
Bis sie quasi warm wurden
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das anders beschreiben soll
Das nennt sich auch Cold und Warm
Also sprich, wenn die eine Weile nicht benutzt wurden
Dann sind die quasi, kann man sich so vorstellen
So aus dem Cash beim Anbieter rausgeflogen
Und dann mussten die teilweise über eine Minute
Kann ich mich auch daran erinnern, am Anfang war es teilweise über eine Minute
Mussten die Dinger neu starten, dass sie wieder funktionieren
Eine klassische API bekommt man auch einen Request
Und sendt eine Antwort zurück
Wann verwendet man das? Was? Das ist das Gleiche
Du kannst auch eine API über Functions bauen
Vom Ansatz her ist das ja alles
Es kommt ein Request rein, du schickst einfach nur zurück
Bei einer API hast du meist noch eine eigene Datenbank
Wo du dann Logik noch drin hast
Aber ich kann jetzt keinen riesen Rundumschlag machen
Sondern um die Vor- und Nachteile
Du bekommst Skalierung mehr oder weniger umsonst
Wenn du deine Functions ordentlich programmierst
Wenn du natürlich in deiner Funktion dann wieder einen Request machst
Irgendwo anders hin
Der dann dort irgendwie gelockt werden muss
Und nur einer laufen kann und so
Dann nicht
Aber wenn die Stateless, der Chat weiß Bescheid
Wenn die Dinge mehr oder weniger Stateless sind
Oder zumindest auf irgendeine
Ähm
Nennen wir es mal Datenbank
Auf irgendeine Persistenz-Layer zugreifen
Der zumindest nicht darauf angewiesen ist
Das irgendwie großartig zu locken ist ja auch okay
Komplett Stateless kannst du im Prinzip vergessen
Weil du willst ja irgendwas machen
Komplett Stateless heißt ja
Du kannst anhand des Inputs immer sagen
Was für einen Output kommen soll im Endeffekt
Ohne dass du irgendwoher was anderes brauchst
Das wird in der Regel
Ja
Wenn du nicht gerade keckw antworten willst
Auf jede Anfrage relativ schwierig
Zumindest wenn du nichts
Wenn du irgendwie keine Persistenz-Sachen hast
Die dann auch
Also wenn du zum Beispiel
Eine SQLite-Datenbank hast
Hinter irgendeiner API
Und du machst darauf
Auf eine Million Request hochskalierte Functions
Dann auf die SQLite-Datenbank
Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht gut funktionieren
Also ja man bekommt quasi Skalierung umsonst
Aber man darf es nicht total hirnlos machen
Das ist das was ich sagen wollte
Also du bekommst Skalierung mehr oder weniger umsonst
Du musst dich nicht um die Infrastruktur kümmern
Das ist gerade für viele Entwickler ein riesen Bonuspunkt
Die haben nämlich aus irgendwelchen Gründen
Keinen Bock darauf
Was ich persönlich nicht so genau verstehe
Weil ich bin da mal
Ich unterscheide das gar nicht
Ich interessiere mich sowohl für die Infrastruktur
Als eben auch für Anwendungsentwicklung
Ich interessiere mich eigentlich für recht breites Feld
Klar ich habe so ein paar Themen
Die interessieren mich besonders
Und mit denen kenne ich mich auch tiefgreifend aus
Aber mich interessiert vieles
Ich kann Entwickler nicht verstehen
Die sagen so nach dem Motto
Alles außerhalb von meiner IDE interessiert mich nicht
Ja
Also das verstehe ich persönlich nicht
Und wir haben auch jede Menge Leute auf der Arbeit
Das ist so nach dem Motto
Was nicht in meiner IDE ist juckt mich nicht
Das verstehe ich nicht
Ich meine
Man sieht es doch allein schon an meinen Stream Inhalten
Dass mich das auf allen möglichen Ebenen interessiert
Wir programmieren Web Anwendungen
Wir machen Backends Sachen
Wir machen Web Anwendungen
Wir skripten irgendwelche Sachen
Wir bauen Cloud Geschichten auf
Wir machen irgendwelche VMs
Wir probieren irgendwelche
Alles mögliche aus
Also man muss das sagen
Was wir hier im Stream oder chat
Was wir hier im Stream an Technik machen
Ist wirklich durch die Bankweg eigentlich mehr oder weniger fast alles
Wir haben C++ gemacht
Wir haben Microcontroller gemacht
Wir haben Web Frontends gemacht
Wir haben Backends Sachen gemacht
Wir haben sogar mal was mit Go gemacht
Wir haben Porksmogs Zeug gemacht
Wir haben ESX auf Raspberry Pi gemacht
Wir haben China-Chinesen Zeug geflasht
Also wir haben in der Richtung fast alles
Also fast jedes Themengebiet
Windows Server
Ich erinnere mich mit Grauen dran alter
Sogar Rust haben wir schon mal 5 Minuten was gemacht
Also wir haben fast fast jedes Themengebiet
Was irgendwie aktuell ein bisschen relevant ist
Schon mal ansatzweise Cobol haben wir auch gemacht
Wir haben fast alles mal irgendwie schon gestreift
Hardware Zeug haben wir auch gemacht
Wir haben China Zeug geflasht
Wir haben den Microserver gebaut
Wir haben letztens am Access Point rumgeschraubt
Ja gut ich meine was ich hier nicht mache ist
Wir bauen jetzt irgendwie
Was sollen wir Hardware Zeug denn hier großartig auch machen
Ich habe mir keine 4HE-Kiste auf Ebay gekauft
Und wir haben dann zusammen rumgewurstet
Aber wozu?
Also wir haben ja mehr oder weniger fast jedes Themengebiet im Stream schon mal irgendwie gestreift
Ok außer Spieleentwicklung
Das juckt mich nicht aber
Also das meiste haben wir schon mal irgendwie gestreift
Deswegen kann ich nicht verstehen
Dass Entwickler sagen juckt mich nicht
Alles außerhalb meiner Idee ist mir egal
Also ich bin der Meinung wenn man ein guter Entwickler ist
Das ist so guck mal
Wenn du ein guter Admin sein willst
Solltest du dich auch ein bisschen dafür interessieren
Wie der Kram programmiert wird
Und was die so für Sorgen und Probleme haben
Umgedreht finde ich sollte man sich auch als Entwickler ein bisschen dafür interessieren
Worauf die ganze Sache läuft wie das funktioniert
Also ein Entwickler da sagt was meine Idee nicht unterstützt gucke ich mir nicht alles bescheuert
Da haben wir Leute davon
Nicht zu wenige
Letztens hat mir ein Entwickler erzählt
Wie ich auf die Idee komme dass das Zertifikat in sieben Tagen abläuft
Weil ich reingeguckt habe das läuft in sieben Tagen ab
Und dann meinte der zu mir irgendwie sowas in der Richtung wie
Ne ne das läuft doch erst 2063 ab
Und dann hat er den Unterschied nicht gecheckt zwischen
Das ist von der CA das Zertifikat was abläuft
Also das von der Zertifizierungsstelle
Also sprach sie die Zertifizierungsstelle selbst läuft ab
Versus und unser Zertifikat
Versus uns die Zertifizierungsstelle also die CCA Ausgestellung läuft ab
War eben nicht klar
Was gar nicht mal so das Problem ist
Wenn man dann nicht darauf besteht dass man recht hat
Beziehungsweise so tut als ist man voll überlegen und hat voll den Durchblick und sowas
So Leute triggern mich immer ungemein
Kennt ihr das Leute die Bullshit erzählen aber diese Sachen
So unglaublich selbstsicher und überzeugend rüber bringen
Das ist eigentlich jeder der keine Ahnung von dem Thema hat glaubt
Ja das Gut Zertifikat von der von der CA also das eigentliche
CA Zertifikat ist 2063 abgelaufen
Das ist das ist der Wahnsinn
Und das geht nicht anders
Ein Entwickler muss heute bisschen Ahnung haben von der ganzen Sache drum herum
Nicht zumindest der Meinung und ein Admin
Du das mit 2063 habe ich jetzt einfach nur gesagt
Es war viel viel weiter in der Zukunft
Ja das war nicht 2063
Ich habe es euch erzählt was 2032 oder so wahrscheinlich
Ich habe es euch erzählt als es so war
Ich habe jetzt einfach nur irgendwas gesagt was ganz weit in der Zukunft ist
Es war nicht wirklich 2063 aber es war ganz ganz weit in der Zukunft
Ja und ein Admin muss gucken was er was er betreibt
Und was da so die Anforderungen sind
Und ich bin sogar der Meinung es ist gar nicht schlecht
Wenn sich jemand dort der bei der Administration ist
Auch mal zeigen lässt von dem Entwickler okay
Wie funktioniert der Kram eigentlich bei unserer Anwendung
Und ich kenne genauso gut jede Menge Admins
Die drehen ab wenn irgendwie ein Entwickler seine Idee aufmacht
Und sagt ich zeig dir mal was sie wollen das nicht sehen
Das ist aber bescheuert
Weil du musst doch wissen was du betreibst
Und umgedreht sollen Entwickler wissen worauf das betrieben wird
Deswegen muss ich sagen ich bin der Meinung full stack ist die Zukunft was das angeht
Gerade im Bereich wenn immer mehr in der Cloud betrieben wird
Wo es sag mal wenig ich sag nicht gar keinen
Aber wo es weniger Daseinsberechtigung für eine Horde klassischer Turnschuh Admins gibt
Das ist das was ich früher gemacht habe
Das ist auch das was ich unglaublich gerne mache
Ich war wirklich gerne Turnschuh Admin in der Zeit wo ich beim Provider war
Ich war täglich im rechten Zentrum mit rumgelaufen
Hab Zeug eingebaut hab Sachen kontrolliert hab Kabel gemacht hab hier und da fand ich super
Ist auch eine Sache die mich persönlich immer noch sehr interessiert
Was Server Hardware und sonst was angeht keine Frage
Aber ich will nicht sagen dass man keine mehr braucht
Das ist Blödsinn weil irgendwo bei den Cloud Anbietern ist auch was ja
Aber der Trend geht eindeutig eher dahin
Dass ich auch größere also größere eh aber auch kleinere mittlere
Dass ich auf allen Ebenen das durchsetzt
Dass man sich überlegt zumindest ob man vielleicht weniger eigenes Rechenzentrum braucht
Also so Turnschuh Admin Geschichten ist nicht am aussterben
Braucht man immer wird man wahrscheinlich immer brauchen
Aber so klassischer Hacker Mans Admin
Der den ganzen Tag quasi im Netzwerkschrank liegt und dort irgendwelche Kabel sucht
Das ist tatsächlich immer immer seltener
So und worauf ich raus will im Hinblick dessen dass es ein bisschen weg davon geht
Finde ich ist voll stack die Zukunft
Du brauchst keinen mehr der super krass Rechenzentrum Skills hat
Wenn du in der Cloud bist du brauchst Leute die Ahnung haben
Von dem was du dort betreibst und gleichermaßen Ahnung haben
Wie man es am besten betreibt und worauf man es betreibt
Es ist Beispiel 2 Beispiel Beispiel
Es ist als Admin sehr schwierig zu sagen
Wie denn eine Anwendung also was denn eine was denn gute Performance bei einer Anwendung ist
Die man nicht programmiert hat ja also es ist sehr schwer zu sagen
Also wenn dich einer fragt so nach dem Motto und wie läuft das wie läuft das Zeug so
Das kannst du schlecht sagen also du weißt nicht
Also zumindest nicht wenn es neu ist du weißt nicht ob jetzt sind jetzt 500 Request gut
1000 Request gut hätten wir vielleicht mit 10.000 Request rechnen müssen die da ohne Probleme durchgehen
Bei der aktuellen Hardware das kann das ist das ist schwer zu sagen
Ja also die meist mit der Zeit kriegt man das natürlich raus
Mit der Zeit kriegt man zum Beispiel raus okay im normalen Betrieb haben wir da irgendwie durchschnittlich
5000 User drauf und die Server langweilen sich so nach dem
Kriegst du mit der Zeit raus aber das ist schwierig aber das ist schwierig da so am Anfang gerade wenn es
Neues Aussagen zuzutreffen das können beispielsweise die Leute die den Krempel entwickelt haben
Deutlich besser weil die wissen was sie da programmiert ich hoffe es mal zumindest bei uns bin ich mir da nicht so ganz sicher
Aber die wissen zumindest was sie programmiert haben und können halbwegs abschätzen okay
Was sind denn so diverse case Szenarien die die passieren können ja zum Beispiel ein Entwickler kann dir sagen okay
Also wenn jetzt 5000 Leute sich einloggen dann ist das kein Problem
Wenn aber 5000 Leute ich muss mir jetzt irgendwelche on the fly irgendwelche Beispiele ausdenken ja
Aber wenn 5000 Leute zufälligerweise gleichzeitig auf PDF generieren drücken
Dann ist es schlecht dann geht es kaputt das weißt du als Admin nicht da hast du keine Ahnung woher sollst du das wissen
Das kriegst du das kriegst du mit Erfahrungswerten über ein paar Monate raus ja
Aber gerade deswegen ist es ja auch wichtig dass die Leute die das programmieren sich Gedanken darüber machen okay
Können wir das nicht vielleicht anders machen ja wenn 5000 Leute auf dem PDF button klicken können und da kacken unsere Systeme ab
Sollten wir sich vielleicht anders machen sollte man das nicht vielleicht lieber irgendwie in irgendeine queue schmeißen
Und über irgendeinen Messagebus Background processen lassen und dann Bescheid sagen wenn es fertig ist oder wisst ihr das sind so Sachen
Ich bin der Meinung das muss Hand in Hand gehen mittlerweile deswegen bin ich auch der Meinung dass der Meinung das full stack die Zukunft ist
Du musst natürlich mit Schwerpunkten du wirst keinen finden der Profi in allem ist und das ist damit auch nicht gemeint
Das heißt also zumindest verstehe ich das nicht da drunter ich verstehe unter full stack nur dass du von allem
Also wie sagt man so schön T shaped ja also dass du Ahnung hast dass du relativ breit Ahnung hast aber du kannst durchaus noch
Deine eins zwei vielleicht drei Spezialgebiete haben das ist gar nicht die Frage also das heißt jetzt nicht
Dass einer der der richtig gut in Infrastruktur ist zwangsläufig jetzt genauso gut
Cobalt programmieren können muss wieder Mainframe Entwickler
Das ist das ist damit das zumindest nicht das was ich mir darunter vorstelle
Aber es ist was ich mir darunter vorstelle ist das aber sowohl der Entwickler ein bisschen Ahnung hat okay mit was haben wir es denn hier zu tun
Worauf wird das ganze deployed wie sehen denn die Kostenpläne dahinter aus
Also sprich es kann ja durchaus sein dass beim jeweiligen Cloud Anbieter diese Funktion spot billig ist
Aber wenn ich dann irgendwie auf krasse Single Core Performance brauche dann ist es super teuer und sowas ja also
Dass die Leute programmieren dann schon ein bisschen Ahnung haben von dem worauf das läuft worauf das deployed wird
Und dass die Leute die Infrastruktur machen aber auch ein bisschen Ahnung haben müssen von dem was die Anwendung so treiben
Ja
Das ist das was ich mir so unter Full Stack vorstelle und nicht eine IT Abteilung in einer Person die alles kann
Weil eine Person die alles kann ist utopisch das wird nicht funktionieren
Du kannst nicht einen haben der Monitoring macht der Infrastruktur macht der Hochverfügbarkeit Cluster genügt macht
Der Datenbanken macht der dann auch noch Anwendung programmiert Telefonie macht also es geht nicht das klappt nicht
Aber wenn jeder ein bisschen und es muss ja nicht jeder Ahnung von haben aber der Willen ein bisschen über den Tellerrand zu gucken
Und nicht standardmäßig zu sagen die anderen haben keine Ahnung und so die wichtig sind ein bisschen anzug das reicht ja eigentlich schon
Machs auch viel mit dem Fabian ich hab lange mit dem Fabian nicht mehr geredet ich würde fällt mir bei der Gelegenheit
Irgendwie hätte ich mal echt Bock wieder mit dem Fabian einfach mal ohne Video so einfach mal ein zwei Stunden sinnloses Zeug schwätzen haben wir lange nicht mehr gemacht
Ja aber wir waren ja ursprünglich noch bei Serverless Functions ich hab mich etwas sidetracken lassen also du kriegst in der Regel die Skalierung umsonst
Du musst dich nicht um die Infrastruktur kümmern für Entwickler ist es meistens eine coole Geschichte
Weil sie einfach einfach sei mal Antwortlichen weil sie einfach auf einen Deploy Button drücken können und es ist da
Also ohne sich irgendwie Gedanken machen zu müssen was weiß ich ich muss einen Server mir bestellen lassen dann muss ich mir von irgendeinem Admin anhören
So nach dem Motto ja das ist doch eigentlich viel zu viel und sonst was also für Entwickler ist Serverless Functions meistens auch super angenehme Geschichte
Die Skalierung ist meistens relativ einfach sonst auch so für Vorteile ja gut es ist es wird zwangsweise relativ modular wenn du das mit Functions machst
Das kann jetzt eine gute und eine schlechte Sache sein aber es wird zwangsläufig relativ modular du hast keinen Controller mehr für du hast keinen Api Controller mehr mit 80.000 Zeilen
Du hast verschiedene Functions ja das mal überlegen was können Nachteile gibt es genug werde ich auch gleich noch was zu erzählen
Chat was sagt ihr was haben wir noch für was haben wir noch für Vorteile die mir gerade nicht einfallen ja Kosten okay Kosten ist ein zweischneidiges Schwert
Kosten also Kosten bei Functions von der Idee her kannst du damit Geld sparen wenn und ich muss gleich ich muss jetzt explizit ich spreche da nicht aus Erfahrung
Weil ich mit Abrechnung bei uns und ich hab keine Ahnung ich krieg das nicht mit es ist aber nur aus dem was ich mir so zusammenreime und aus dem was ich so sehe was der Kram kostet
Also beziehungsweise die Kostenpläne sehen also du kannst theoretisch mit Serverless und Functions Geld sparen wenn du ein gewisses Up und Down drinne hast
Also sprich wenn du mal 10 Benutzer hast und mal 5000 wenn du solche Sachen hast ja so was weiß ich nachts sind weniger tagsüber sind viel viel mehr
Also du brauchst so ein bisschen Up und Down drinne so und dieses Up und Down muss es überwiegen die Infrastruktur hinzustellen
Also wenn du einfach 2 VMs hinstellen kannst bei Hetzner und du wirst deinen Load easy abfackeln den ganzen Tag über es gibt nie Probleme
Dann wirst du wahrscheinlich mit 2 virtuellen Servern deutlich billiger fahren als mit irgendwelchen Servern das gedürzt
Wenn du jetzt allerdings 2 Server vielleicht für deine Grundrauschen hinkommst aber manchmal was weiß ich weil die Leute irgendwie einmal im Monat eine Abrechnung machen
Oder einmal in der Woche was großes passiert aber keine Ahnung ist auch egal was und du bräuchtest auf einmal anstatt 2-3 VMs bräuchtest du auf einmal 100 VMs
Und das möglichst schnell skaliert dann kannst du eventuell sogar mal sparen mit Functions
So wie gesagt ich spreche da explizit nicht aus Erfahrung weil ich unsere Abrechnungsgeschichten nicht kenne
Aber so habe ich mir das zusammen gereimt aber ich würde sagen das Function nicht primär ein super krasses Kostenersparungsinstrument ist pauschal
Schau mal gar nicht wenn du eh kaum Last drauf hast
Würdest du gerne mit dir zusammen vielleicht sind wir irgendwann mal kann doch sein weiß man ja nicht muss doch mal konsultant werden
Wie gesagt meinen ersten freelancing Programmierauftrag habe ich ja auch mittlerweile erledigt
Wer weiß was da noch kommt ja
Und ja aber gerade wenn du von dieser Skalierungsmöglichkeit profitierst dann ist das eine super Sache und dann kannst du damit auch Geld sparen
Bist du nicht nicht wirklich nicht wirklich also ich suche nicht aktiv irgendwas oder so
Genau so also das würde ich sagen Vorteile Nachteile tja es kann ganz schnell saumäßig teuer werden
Das ist eine der Nachteile von Functions wenn du nämlich nicht aufpasst oder deine Limits nicht richtig gesetzt hast
Dann kannst du ganz schnell Probleme haben wenn du Mist programmierst in deinen Functions
Es gibt genug Berichte von Leuten die haben Server des Functions so programmiert dass das Ding sich selbst callt
Und jetzt überlegt euch mal ihr baut aus Versehen eine recursive Funktion
Was meint ihr was das kostet ihr bezahlt pro Aufruf oder oder gut je nachdem
Pro Aufruf pro Auslastung pro Speicherverbrauch oder sowas also je nach Abrechnungsmodell
Also kannst du dir vorstellen das ist heftig also da reden jetzt für Leute die ja gar keine Vorstellungen haben wir reden davon
Du kannst innerhalb von einer Nacht wenn du dich verprogrammierst und zu blöd warst ordentliche Limits zu setzen in deinem Account
Was aber auch blöd ist weil wenn du Limits erreicht hast die Function wie auch immer besser als arm zu werden
Du kannst ohne Probleme stellt euch mal vor nur mal so als Beispiel stellt euch vor ihr deploit das abends noch und geht ins Bett
Und ihr habt irgendwie Mist programmiert dann habt ihr am anderen Morgen 40.000 Euro Cloud Kosten
Das kann locker passieren also das ist so ein Ding wo ich sagen will du musst aufpassen was du programmierst
Und es gibt genug Einträge es gibt genug Videos auf YouTube Leute den das passiert es gibt genug Einträge die darüber berichten
Dass ihnen das bei Cloud anbietern passiert ist 200.000 Einer ja es geht beliebig fast ja das ist heftig
Das ist so das kleine Unternehmen ihr Instant Konkurs fast anmelden könnten wenn da Mist programmiert aber eins muss man sagen
Bei ganz vielen dieser Berichten wurde ihnen das am Ende auch erlassen also die haben sich dann an den Support gewinnt
Und haben gesagt Leute wir haben scheiße programmiert und es gibt nicht wenig Berichte dass der Cloud anbieter das storniert hat danach
Und gesagt dann ist okay also denen ist quasi guter Ruf und Kunden erhalten aktuell wohl wichtiger gewesen als drauf bestehen
Es ist aber natürlich auch kein muss man auch sagen ist auch keine gute Werbung ja wenn sowas möglich ist ohne weiteres
Und der Anbieter sich quer stellt dann auch vielleicht sogar kleinere Startups oder so Instant Konkurs anmelden müssen
Weil sich man bei der Serverless Funktion verprogrammiert haben das ist glaube ich keine gute Werbung für so Hyper Agile Cloud Gedöns
Aber es kann man im Internet nachgucken also es kam relativ häufig am Ende raus dass es nochmal mit einem blauen Auge aus
Durchgekommen sind und sie das nicht bezahlen mussten ja so weitere Nachteile
Ja gut das kann je nachdem was du programmieren musst die Sache unnötig kompliziert machen
Also eine klassische Web Anwendung so nach dem Motto wir nehmen eine VM haben dort Datenbank drauf deployen unsere Web Anwendung drauf
Und starten die ist nicht schlechtes also auch im Jahr 2022 nicht und das ist gerade für kleine Sachen immer noch einfacher
Also je nachdem also wenn du paar Sachen wenn du 5-6 Teile hast die zusammenhängen
Du brauchst irgendwas Persistentes mit einer Datenbank sprich nichts dagegen den Linux Server zu mieten
Du kannst das zwar alles in irgendeiner Art und Weise auch mit Functions machen es gibt ja genug Cloud Datenbanken und alles mögliche mittlerweile
Also einfacher macht es es nicht zwangsläufig es macht das modularer auf jeden Fall
Meinst du mit die B-Tragonball ja was sonst das muss es nicht unbedingt einfacher machen
Und dazu kommt bei kleinen Sachen ist es wahrscheinlich auch einfacher und billiger wenn du die einfach irgendwo eine VM hinstellst
Das nächste ist bei Functions musst du immer noch Kleinigkeiten beachten die Probleme die du bei eigener Infrastruktur bei dem Server nicht hast
Zum Beispiel Cold Start Zeiten da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher wie das mittlerweile aussieht
Cold Start Time keine Ahnung
Ja genau du kannst auch noch einstellen ob die überhaupt jemals kalt werden und sonst was
Also je nachdem welchen Plan du nimmst und bei welchem Function Anbieter du bist kann es sein wenn die Function eine Weile nicht aufgerufen wurde
Dass sie quasi nicht mehr hot ist und dann beim ersten neuen Aufruf Minute ist übertrieben aber spürbar braucht bis sie erst mal gestartet ist dass sie überhaupt losläuft
Das sind so Dinge da musst du dir bei deinem eigenen Server keine Gedanken drüber machen der ist immer da und wenn du ihm einen Request schickst
Egal ob es einer ist und dann drei Tage nichts und dann wieder einen der macht das einfach es ist einfach was anderes
Ja und Vorteil gegenüber klassischen Apis muss ich dir ehrlich sagen je nachdem was du machen willst ist eine Web Anwendung wo du 10 Endpoints hast für irgendwas
Wahrscheinlich simpler gemacht mit einer klassischen Web Anwendung als das alles in Functions aufstücke und dann irgendwie gucken wie kriege ich da mein Stateless wirklich ist ja eigentlich fast nichts in der echten Welt
Wie kriege ich da eigentlich mein Zeug synchronisiert und sonst was wahrscheinlich würde ich eine stinknormale Web Anwendung machen
Da muss ich aber sagen Disclaimer ich habe zwar prinzipiell Plan von aber ich habe noch nie eine reine Serverless Anwendung programmiert also ich habe noch nie was gebastelt
Was in irgendeiner Art und Weise Persistenz hat weil es sich halt auch Sachen merken muss und irgendeine Logik hat und Web Frontend oder so rein mit Functions habe ich noch nie gemacht
Doch ne Lambda habe ich immer ehrlich gesagt das haben wir sogar im Stream zusammen gemacht das habe ich alles schon gemacht aber ich habe noch nie eine Anwendung gebaut die nur Serverless Kram verwendet
Dementsprechend kann ich da jetzt auch abschließen nicht wirklich ganz in der Tiefe so viel zu sagen ja als Chat wenn euch noch was einfällt schreibt es rein
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen was hier geschrieben wurde
Die Router anliegen Switch dazwischen und mit einer freien App hier in den rollenden Router angeklemmt was ok du hast ein Provider Router dahinter hast du einen Switch
Das geht um den Weg raus sondern es geht um den Weg rein also es ging doch darum dass sie irgendwie intern eine Firewall haben die ihre Systeme schützen soll aber irgendjemand da einfach dran vorbei kommt
Was ja nur funktioniert wenn du in das Zielnetz in irgendeiner Art und Weise in zweiten Gateway ach so jetzt weiß ich wie du das meinst du meinst auch den umgekehrten Weg das irgendwie ja aber ja gut
Aber ne das kann nicht sein die sind die sind an einem anderen Standort über den VPN dann ist das dann ist das trotzdem blöd konfiguriert es darf einfach es darf keinen anderen Eingang geben in das Netz als über die Firewall zu gehen
Und eine Sache bei diesen ganzen Cloud Themen es gibt immer sehr viel über Lagerungen also du kannst echt schlecht sagen wo Functions aufhören und Serverless anfängt und Managed Hosting anfängt wo Managed Hosting aufhört das ist alles fließend
Natürlich kann man sagen Functions ist ein Bestandteil von Serverless und in irgendeiner Art und Weise gehört das alles irgendwie zu Managed Hosting wobei es dann wieder die Frage ist wie Managed Hosting definiert ist
Viele würden jetzt wahrscheinlich sagen ja da geht es doch bloß darum dass du dir irgendwelche VMs zusammenklickst also je nachdem wen du fragst also das ist schwierig
Stimmt richtig Chat ihr seid pfeifert
Ja mein Azure Account mein privater Azure Account wurde gesperrt Leute ich habe mir einen Trial Account aufgemacht mit 100 Euro Startguthaben vor einem halben Jahr oder so und danach habe ich was habe ich denn Böses gemacht
Ich glaube ich habe meine Handynummer entfernt danach oder irgendwie sowas und das nächste Mal als ich mich dann einloggen wollte ein paar Wochen später hat Microsoft gesagt es wurden verdächtige Aktivitäten auf ihrem Account festgestellt bitte hinterlegen sie irgendwie aktuelle Dingsnummer und habe ich gesagt ne mach ich nicht
Und jetzt ist er glaube ich weg das müssen wir echt mal ausprobieren ein Digital Ocean Editor also was ich bei Digital Ocean früher oft verwendet habe sind die VMs ich verwende übrigens regelmäßig noch Digital Ocean VMs nämlich in Bangalore wisst ihr wo Bangalore ist Leute Bangalore
Das ist in Indien und wenn man über Indien ein YouTube Abo abschließen möchte ist das sinnvoll einen Endpunkt in Indien zu haben und ich erstelle mir ab und zu mal in Indien bei Digital Ocean in Bangalore eine VM und tunnel mich dann per Socksbroxy und meinem Browser über Indien und schließt ein YouTube Premium Abo ab
für 299 Indische Rupien also irgendwie umgerechnet 2,50 Euro oder so das ist deutlich billiger als in Deutschland
Ja das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut man kann zwar vieles auch zeitgesteuert auswählen aber in der Regel man könnte eigentlich sagen Serverless Function ist im Prinzip das was du in deiner Web Anwendung in so eine Controller Methode schreibst ja
Du machst einen Controller für irgendwie slash plupp get slash plupp Controller Methode und dieser Block der Controller Methode das ist quasi das was du Standalone in so eine Funktion reinkopieren kannst du bekommst ein Request rein und musst irgendeine Antwort rauspusten
Wie heißt nochmal der Proxy Cash mit dem OctoSquid meinst du? Das ist auch der einzige Proxy der mir jetzt pauschal so einfällt ich meine es gibt noch HA Proxy aber HA Proxy ist was ganz was anderes
HA Proxy ist eher ein TCP und HTTP Load Balancer als ein Proxy Server also Squid ist Caching Proxy quasi eher ausgehend ins Internet und HA Proxy ist eigentlich eher Load Balancer Reverse Proxy technisch Load Balancer mäßig eingehend
Ja meint er wahrscheinlich ja ich glaube da bestreitet keiner
Wobei es halt je nach Unternehmen und je nach Abend durchaus mehr oder weniger Überschneidungen gibt
Powered by Go und Rust ne ne das geht anders wenn du irgendwas programmierst und auf Github pusht und es ist in Rust oder Go programmiert musst du dir einen coolen Titel ausdenken und dann musst du in die Beschreibung reinschreiben
Written in Go Written in Rust und dann gehst du auf Hacker News und postest dein Projekt mit einer coolen Beschreibung und dann hoffst du dass es gut ankommt und viele Benutzer und Sterne bekommt
Und dann ein Maskottchen mit mit Gopher oder wie dieser Typ heißt genau und dann brauchst du irgendein Maskottchen für dein Go Go Lang Projekt was dieses Go Maskottchen in irgendeiner Art und Weise umwurstet zu deinem Projekt Maskottchen
Und dann bist du voll im Trend und wenn du Rust machst wenn du Rust machst dann nimmst du diese komische Krabbe ich weiß nicht wie die Krabbe heißt wie heißt sie Rust Crab Paris ja die da die orange Krabbe
How to erfolgreiches Projekt auf Github launchen erstens in Go oder Rust programmieren zweitens cooles Maskottchen drittens post auf Hacker News und jetzt mal ganz Spaß beiseite was wirklich hilft
Oder was ich mir wünschen würde von vielen Projekten macht eine ordentliche Read Me ich hab keinen Bock mir den Kram erst installieren zu müssen dass ich weiß wie das Web Interface aussieht ich hab auch keinen Bock erstmal die Read Me durchzulesen und um zu checken was es überhaupt macht
Read Me am Anfang Minimal Beispiel wenn es eine Library ist das macht diese Library so benutzt man das Minimal Beispiel drei Zeilen wenn es ein Web Interface gibt Demo das kann auf irgendeinem low cost Bilder sowieso aber Demo ist richtig geil wenn es eine Demo gibt
Es kann auf irgendeinem ultra low cost free Computing Node am Arsch der Welt in Bangladesch sein in der Cloud oder so das ist egal Hauptsache es gibt eine Demo und wenn da noch Screenshots dabei sind also wenn das Ding eine gute Beschreibung hat in den ersten paar Sätzen was es ist
Ein Minimal Beispiel paar Features aufgelistet was ist daran gut warum hat man das entwickelt was sind die Vorzüge davon schöne Screenshots vom Interface dass man sieht was man da Vorsicht hat gleich Installationsanleitung ja und nach Möglichkeit halt sowas was passt für die Leute die es ganz eilig haben einen Befehl Docker Run BAM so könnt ihr das Ding starten und ausprobieren und dann vielleicht für die Leute noch hier habt ihr noch ein Befehl das und das
hier Binary runterladen das ist go starten und gutes Installationsanleitung und dann wenn es wirklich mehr braucht natürlich auch noch die Funktion ein bisschen beschreiben aber das erste reicht schon und das verkacken so viele Leute ich sehe so viele GitHub Projekte die ich aufmache und die eigentlich cool sind aber die einfach nur Fragezeichen erzeugen
Platte haben wir auch schon gemacht ja
Ich habe diesen Cobalt in HTML gemacht fühl dich auf zu verraten
Es wird ein bisschen schwierig
Und für vieles ist es bescheuert in die IDE reinzupacken warum soll ich einen Browser in die IDE reinpacken
Ja das ist Wahnsinn wenn ich das sehe dass Entwickler beispielsweise noch nicht mal in der Lage sind SSH zu verwenden ich meine hallo SSH ist eines der most basic Sachen schlechthin
Äh ich programmiere seit zwei Jahren und bin jetzt der einzige Entwickler in der Anteile und muss ein Projekt abschließen leider fühle ich mich doch da hast du Tipps für mich
Ähm ich kenne den Laden nicht aber ich weiß nicht wie gut du mit deinem Chef klar kommst ich würde das mal ansprechen und mal dein oder ich würde mir vorher was aufschreiben und ich würde das mal ansprechen und sagen wie stellt man sich das eigentlich vor
Also was sind denn eigentlich die Anforderungen an mich dass sie das mal klar formulieren was die eigentlich von dir wollen ja und dann sagst du ok und wie ist das und dann wie sie das denn realistisch aussieht und wie sie das denn realistischerweise und was sie daran ändern wollen dass du das vielleicht alleine gar nicht hinbekommst
Also ich würde da mal mit meinem Chef ganz normal drüber reden so wie stellt man sich das eigentlich vor je nachdem ob du mit dem gut klar kommst ansonsten wenn das eh ein Kackladen ist und du denkst da wird sich eh nichts ändern und du das nicht machen willst dann ja was anderes
Und dass du überfordert bist ist ja logisch das liegt nicht daran weil du blöd bist dass gerade Leute die gerade high IQ Fifet Leute habe ich den Eindruck also Chat ihr seid mit gemeint ja
Reden sich das öfters ein dass es an ihnen liegt wenn sie was nicht checken oder wenn es an dass es an ihnen liegt wenn sie irgendwas nicht nicht auf die Reihe bekommen aber es gibt nur so viel was man mit 500 IQ machen kann
Lahn und Chef ist super da würde ich mit meinem Chef drüber reden wenn er super ist es gibt nur so viel was man mit 500 IQ machen kann und da könnt ihr auch so viele Prime Subscriptions reinhauen wie ihr wollt weil ihr wisst ja jeder Prime Sub und es ist nicht IQ plus plus sondern plus plus IQ
Plus plus wird vorher ausgewertet IQ plus plus wird nachher ausgewertet da bringen euch alle Prime Subs der Welt hier an der Stelle nichts es gibt einfach nur so viel was man machen kann und es gibt auch nur so viel wovon man Ahnung haben kann
Und wenn man der einzige Entwickler ist und alles auf einen einprasselt und jeder irgendwas will das funktioniert nicht je nachdem wie komplex das ganze ist und das liegt sehr wahrscheinlich nicht an dir
Vielleicht sind die auch einfach nur gewöhnt dass du es irgendwie auf Lasten deiner eigenen Gesundheit irgendwie schon fixst
Gibt es ja genug ja gibt ja genug Unternehmen die haben denen ist das egal die sagen im Endeffekt so nach dem Motto ja gut Hauptsache das funktioniert jetzt ob die Leute dann in fünf Jahren irgendwie sterben oder so ist uns egal
ist jetzt übertrieben ausgedrückt ist uns egal Hauptsache es klappt jetzt irgendwie also sprich wenn du die Sachen irgendwie noch auf letzten Drücker fix im zweifelsfall auch mal irgendwie nachts um um 0 30 oder so weil es sich fertig wird das kann es auch nicht sein
die laut die musik ja also ich würde da mit dem chef mal drüber reden erstens also wenn es nur zweimal erstens was man eigentlich genau von die erwartet in diesem in dieser konstellation und dann sagst du deine Probleme und dann wie man sich das denn vorstellt dass das denn laufen soll
beste
also ganz ehrlich wenn man sie also ich weiß nicht wie viele leute es da gibt aber ich ich kann jetzt nur von mir ausgehen ich interessiere mich da für alle möglichen seiten wir programmieren hier viel wir machen auch viel technik was
administration angeht und ich bin bestimmt nicht der einzige der sich IT technisch für breites spektrum interessiert ich gehe sogar so weit und sagt die leute die wirklich gut in diesem job sind die interessieren sich für vieles und auch für vieles was vielleicht nie
ihr fachgebiet wird aber die finden es einfach interessant mal so ein bisschen rum zu gucken ja ich möchte beispielsweise auch nie hauptberuflich css design machen da würde ich meinen rechner täglich zerstören aber ich finde es zumindest mal ganz spannend ein bisschen ahnung davon zu haben
so
das
deswegen jetzt ja auch nicht darum also das ist ja keine alles oder nichts frage also wenn du jemand hast der hoch spezialisiert ist dann heißt es ja nicht zwangsläufig dass er bei allem anderen von tuten und blasen überhaupt keine ahnung haben muss also dass der da im detail jetzt nicht großartig was machen kann ist klar aber dass der so
basics zumindest schon mal gehört hat oder weiß wie man das benutzt ja also ich kann es doch immer ein entwickler zumuten selbst wenn ich einen super krass hoch spezialisierten geilen cobalt mainframe entwickler habe von dem kann ich durchaus erwarten dass der comments in git machen kann und dass er ssh verwenden kann das sind solche sachen und im prinzip wird es bei jedem darauf rauslaufen dass der sich eins zwei drei
je nachdem was es so ist steckenpferde sucht das ist ja so es gibt ja es gibt ja bereiche die interessieren dich besonders oder die machen hier besonders spaß oder du machst schon besonders lang hast dementsprechend viel ahnung also jeder wird sich ja früher oder später so eins zwei steckenpferde suchen was es denn ist oder was was man denn macht und
das ist ja nicht dass du in allem anderen gar keine ahnung haben kannst oder haben wirst
das ist tatsächlich der das ist tatsächlich so das fangt mich übrigens bei uns auch am meisten ab dass es so viel unsinnliche unklare sachen gibt und bürokratische hürden und das obwohl sie seit jahren was erzählen von wir haben wir verbessern unsere prozesse und wir haben
jetzt sogar consultants gekauft die unsere prozesse verbessern und sonst was aber im endeffekt die prozesse halten alle den ersten kontakt mit der realität nicht stand und leider sind es die leute die mit daran beteiligt waren diese prozesse zu etablieren die ersten die sich nicht daran halten beziehungsweise dann auch nicht einsehen wollen dass man dann
halt das anpassen muss dass es in zukunft besser passt sondern lieber extrawurst machen wir haben wenn es da war wenn es danach geht haben wir einen haufen extrem unfähige leute in diesen gebieten wenn es um sowas geht weil es kann auch nicht sein dass du quasi mit hilfst sowas zu erstellen und dann derjenige bist der dir als erstes die extrawurst macht und ich bin bei uns mittlerweile auch nicht sicher ob der ob ob das gesunde
verhältnis noch gewahrt ist also sprich das gesunde verhältnis aus sag es mal übertrieben sessel furzer jobs die prozesse machen den ganzen tag und leute die am endeffekt dann dafür sorgen dass denn alle arbeiten können inklusive denen die im endeffekt das geld verdienen ich bin mir nicht sicher ob da die gesunde gesunde verhältnis
bei uns noch gewahrt ist ja also mal in meinem gefühl nach das muss natürlich nicht stimmen ist bei uns mittlerweile es ein wenig verschoben in richtung bürokratische hürden die die leute selber nicht mehr verstehen die sie eingeführt haben versus die die im endeffekt dafür sorgen müssen dass wir überleben und geld verdienen
ne ne sind nicht tausend häuptlinge und zwar in jahre häuptlinge haben wir gar nicht immer so viele wobei die häuptlinge bei uns zum größten teil ja also ich rede jetzt von mittlere mittlere management und rüber die sagen alles soll agil sein aber machen dann selbst exakt das gegenteil davon und sie sagen dann auch solche dinge wie
ja bei problemen sollen in zukunft keine schuldigen mehr gesucht werden sondern lösungen und dann sind die gleichen leute das sagen auf irgendwelchen störungsrunden und als erstes kommt ja wer war denn da zu dem zeitpunkt wo es kaputt gegangen ist und dann denke ich mir immer so wie kannst du an dem einen tag das sagen voller überzeugungen am anderen tag das das passt einfach nicht zusammen
oder dass man heute sagt ja wir werden dieses produkt einführen und dann sagt jemand ja moment wenn wir dieses produkt jetzt so einführen ohne das andere zu machen dann ist das aber ein bisschen ein bisschen instabil das können schon in die hose gehen und dann sagt man dann nein das ist egal wir führen das neue produkt so und so ein so wie ich das gesagt habe und die probleme die da auf uns zukommen das ist einfach nicht zusammen
so ein so wie ich das gesagt habe und die probleme die da auf uns zukommen die nehmen wir in kauf die tragen wir dann zusammen so und dann geht es kaputt und dann wird man will man von dieser aussage nichts wissen also man möchte nichts mehr von der aussage wissen die man getroffen hat vor einem halben jahr noch
also sprich das ist das was was für mich auch sag mal mal gute gute manager auszeichnet ich verlange nicht das manager immer richtig liegen die können ich schreibe mir mittlerweile sowas auch auf und ich habe mich aber manchen stellen schon nicht letztens habe ich einen anschluss gekriegt das muss ich euch glaube ich noch erzählen das war auch witzig das war genau auf so einer runde ja ich habe mich da auch manchmal schon nicht sonderlich beliebt gemacht also bei uns ist es teilweise so man macht dann hier die große strategie verkündung
und dann gibt es natürlich leute die sagen ja ok beißt sich ein bisschen mit sachen die wir in der vergangenheit gemacht haben aber muss ja nicht so sein können wir machen und dann wird dann groß erzählt so nach dem motto da müssen wir jetzt durch und gut ist und wir tragen das und dann geht was kaputt und dann wird danach gesagt das das das seid ihr dran schuld ich habe meine entscheidungen haben damit nichts zu tun so und das ist das was für mich auch einen guten manager ausmachen wie gesagt ich erwarte nicht dass der immer richtig liegt
oder dass er das auch immer alles richtig einschätzen kann ne aber was ich erwarte ist wie von jedem anderen der dort arbeitet auch dass er nicht die fehler prinzipiell die fault mäßig erstmal woanders sucht es ist ja so man kann selten wenn was in die hose gegangen ist das einem zuordnen so direkt man kann sagen ja das ist meist verkettung mehrerer umstände aber was mir bei uns etwas abgeht ist das reflektiv
ihren eigener entscheidungen und das bedeutet auch dass man sich auf management ebene fragen muss ok es ist jetzt da und dabei zwar kaputt gegangen aber warum wurde das denn überhaupt gemacht das wurde gemacht weil ich das so wollte vor einem halben jahr
so und dieser punkt ist bei uns so gut wie nie ich glaube ich habe noch nicht einmal gehört von mittlere management und weiter oben drüber in der langen zeit wo ich jetzt da bin obwohl es an vielen stellen sehr offensichtlich war dass man sich basslos verkalkuliert hat und verschätzt hat
ich habe nicht einmal gehört dass man gesagt ok das liegt auch mit daran wir werden das jetzt in zukunft besser machen das wäre deutlich überzeugender als dieses bei uns geht nie was schief weil man sieht dass es schief geht und da kann man nicht danach sagen bei uns geht nie was schiefes gehen offensichtlich sachen schief
also sprich das würde ich wirklich erwarten von von einem fähigen management dass man da auch sagen kann ok wir haben die entscheidungen wir haben die man muss ja nicht sagen wir haben verkackt ja man kann ja sagen wir haben die entscheidungen damals getroffen aufgrund der informationen und aufgrund der sachlage die damals uns vorgelegen hat und uns erschien es als der beste weg das so zu machen
jetzt haben wir aber gelernt aus diesen weil was kaputt gegangen ist wir haben jetzt daraus gelernt wir werden das jetzt in zukunft beachten und wir werden das jetzt in zukunft anders machen und es dann auch im besten fall noch machen ja das würde mir ja schon komplett reichen dass jetzt da irgendeiner sagt oh leute ich habe mich total vertan ich habe es verkackt schwachsinn würde ich auch so nicht machen aber man kann doch durchaus sagen ok das liegt aufgrund der sachlage
das hat sich jetzt rausgestellt unsere einschätzung damals aufgrund der vorliegenden verhältnisse war war nicht richtig nicht zutreffen wir haben festgestellt so kann man es besser machen so machen wir das jetzt alles ok aber das passiert nicht
also ja dazu leute in zehn minuten bin ich weg aber trotzdem das muss ich sagen dazu ich hatte mal ich schon eine ganze weile her ein meeting mit zwei entwicklern und die wollten irgendeine web anwendung laufen lassen ich glaube und ich bin mir nicht ganz ich glaube es war irgendwas wordpress basiert das damals
irgendeine ich glaube irgendwie eine unserer 50 milliarden webseiten die wir so betreiben war das mit ein bisschen spezial zeug und da ging es damals noch drum ja welche hardware sollen wir euch denn zur verfügung stellen ne ne ne krass ne anders anders nicht welche hardware sollen wir euch zur verfügung stellen
haben wir gefragt ja und wie sieht das so aus was rechnet man da so mit anfragen wie sieht es denn so mit performance aus haben wir gesagt wir brauchen eine super performance super leistungsfähige hardware und dann haben wir gesagt ja ok aber da packen wir es auf wegen eine vm auf wegen einem cluster wo nicht so viel los ist da kann man im zweifelsfall auch mehr kerne geben und so nein das muss unbedingt auf hardware laufen wir brauchen die top beste performance
da sehr viele requests aber da habe ich den typ gefragt ok was heißt denn sehr viele requests also wie viele requests rechnen wir dann so da hat er gesagt tausend tausend was in in der sekunde oder wie und ich bin mir nicht mal sicher was er gesagt hat aber im prinzip ganz ehrlich mal im ernst alles über eine sekunde ist es ein witz also egal ob es eine minute ist fünf minuten
oder sonst was ist ein witz und selbst je nach anwendung sind tausend in der sekunde und je nach hat kein ding wenn es einfach nur statisches html ist oder so also der war der war super davon überzeugt dass krass viele anfragen kommen aber konnte den nicht sagen wieviel es denn wirklich sind ja sowas finde ich auch immer geil achja was ich euch erzählen wollte noch kurz bevor ich auf gehe ich scroll noch den chat durch dann wo ich letzten anschluss bekommen habe
und zwar letztens ist was kaputt gegangen und ich werde angerufen zum glück tagsüber ja ich werde im teams angerufen von leuten die mich normalerweise nicht anrufen ich wusste zu dem zeitpunkt nicht da war grad irgendein ausfall analyse meeting mit 15 leuten oder so inklusive abteilungsleiter und alle möglichen dabei und
ich habe da nicht angenommen ich habe nicht angenommen ich dachte hier ich bin gerade in einer anderen besprechung kann grad nicht und da kam dann als antwort nur noch so irgendwie sowas wie nach dem motto egal genau kam als antwort egal ich habe ihm geschrieben hier ich bin gerade in irgendeinem daily ich kann grad nicht was ist denn und da hat er mir als antwort geschrieben im teams egal dann habe ich halt zurückgeschrieben nee ist nicht egal ich bin jetzt auf einer anderen runde ich wusste
zu dem zeitpunkt gar nicht dass es um irgendwelche ausfälle geht oder irgendwas kaputt ist das ist was was mir aktuell extrem auf den sack geht bei mir auf der arbeit dass das ist schon so eine unfreundliche aggressive grundhaltung gibt bei vielen leuten was ist das denn für ein umgang du rufst jemand an der eindeutig gerade schon in dem call ist der ist sogar noch so nett und antwortet dir dass er grad nicht kann und du antwortest ihm auf diese sache er kann gar nicht mit egal was ist das für eine beschissene
antwort so habe ich halt jetzt halt nicht egal so und irgendwann hat er dann gesagt ja was kaputt und so warum sagst du das nicht gleich da wäre ich auch rüber gekommen da bin ich rüber in dieses ausfallen
meeting rein wie gesagt mit abteilungsleiter alle möglichen dabei haben wieder ganz ganz stark nach schuldigen gesucht obwohl man das eigentlich nicht macht und da wurde ich gefragt ja max ihr habt doch da wartungsarbeit das sind immer das sind die
besten fragen so max ihr habt doch da wartungsarbeiten gemacht was habt ihr denn da genau gemacht so und bei solchen fragen muss ich mittlerweile immer zurück rudern und sage ich
welche wartungsarbeiten oder besser gesagt sagt mir doch mal was ist denn eigentlich kaputt ja warum was war was für was ist denn die runde hier ich meine wir machen viele wartungsarbeiten wenn der tag lang
ist um was geht es dann genau und dann haben die irgendwelche komischen dinge erzählt von irgendwelchen zertifikaten die auf irgendwelchen mobile anwendungen nicht mehr getrusted werden oder sowas wo ich mir gerade
was um alles in der welt soll das mit irgendwelchen wartungsarbeiten zu tun haben die vielleicht in irgendwelche linux kisten gemacht haben wenn irgendwelche mobile anwendung auf einmal irgendwelche zertifikate nicht mehr
trusten dann haben die mich dazu eingeladen einfach nur just for fun weil ich irgendwelche wartungsarbeiten gemacht habe und man meint ja der könnte ja da was mit zu tun haben ist ja ok sage ich ja prinzipiell gar nichts dagegen ist ja in ordnung zumindest auf dieser runde ging es dann darum dass es es hat sich rausgestellt dass es indirekt doch was mit wartungsarbeiten zu tun hat aber ganz anders als man eigentlich denkt wir haben
routinemäßig ein zertifikat ausgetauscht weil es abläuft muss man machen weil wenn das zertifikat abläuft dann kann gar keiner mehr drauf zugreifen so wir haben unser zertifikat ausgetauscht durch ein komplett gültiges legit zertifikat kein problem so und dann hat sich
rausgestellt dass irgendein 5 header mobile anwendungsentwickler nicht die gültigkeit des zertifikats checkt sondern die ca checkt und die ca ist aber schon eine ganze weile bei uns nicht mehr die wir haben mittlerweile eine ganz andere ca normalerweise checkst du ob das zertifikat gültig ist und nicht das nicht die ca der hat zumindest die ca
checkt und das neue zertifikat war gültig aber von einer anderen ca zertifizierung stelle die die die zertifikate ausstellt und deswegen ging das nicht mehr deswegen war es kaputt so und es hatte also ein bisschen was schon mit
unsere wartungsarbeiten zu tun deswegen war es auch gar nicht verkehrt dass sie mich eingeladen haben so und dann kam dann als lösung raus auf diese meeting ja wir könnten doch temporär das alte zertifikat wieder einspielen damit es jetzt wieder geht so und da habe ich gesagt ja das können wir machen
kein problem wir haben das alte zertifikat ja noch aber wir haben das ja nicht just for fun ausgetauscht das zertifikat läuft in sieben tagen ab und wenn das zertifikat wirklich abläuft in sieben tagen dann ist nicht nur die app kaputt da kann der komplette
außendienst nicht mehr arbeiten in sieben tagen das will ich jetzt hier nochmal so deutlich sagen also dann kann niemand mehr arbeiten im außendienst in sieben tagen wenn das bis dahin nicht wieder zurückgetauscht wird und in dem moment habe ich einen anschiss
gekriegt ich soll mir keine gedanken darüber machen was in sieben tagen ist sondern wir haben jetzt probleme ich habe in dem moment nichts mehr gesagt ich habe ich habe gesagt ja dann nicht ich habe bloß ja dann halt nicht ja ich habe ich habe zu
lange darauf hingewiesen dass es in sieben tagen ein riesen problem gibt und aber wir haben noch jetzt probleme das ging den auf den sack so ich habe ich habe nichts weiter gesagt ich weiß dass die stimmung da eh schon sehr aufgeladen ist ich habe bloß
irgendwas in der richtung gesagt so von mir ja gut dann halt nicht ja dann macht was ihr wollt ja und das geile ist ja das das geile ist ja dass die im anschluss noch nicht mal irgendjemand damit beauftragt haben das jetzt weiter zu verfolgen
also die haben nicht diese nicht aus diesem aus diesem meeting raus und haben jetzt irgendwie einen ausgedeutet der jetzt sich darum kümmert dass das alles in ordnung gebracht wird oder zumindest das koordinieren
ne die haben einfach gesagt ach ja jetzt gehts wieder und es kam nix raus am ende so und wir hatten wirklich sehr viel glück weil ich habe mir nach nach gesagt ich mach nix ich habe das in die retrospektive geschrieben das ist das einzige was ich gemacht habe ich habe darauf bestanden dass das in der retrospektive drin steht mit den sieben tagen abläuft dass es mit sieben tagen abläuft und ansonsten habe ich mir gedacht ihr könnt machen was ihr wollt es mir egal so und die hatten nur glück dass wir an manchen stellen noch paar leute haben
die auch checken was sache ist und jemand aus unserem change management der damit primär gar nicht so viel zu tun hat
hat sich das durchgelesen und hat gesehen ach gucke mal da in sieben tagen haben wir ja einen ausfall für den kompletten außendienst und dann hat er mich noch mal gefragt wie das ist beziehungsweise ich hab ich hab sie ihm dann auch nochmal erzählt und dann hat der obwohl er eigentlich direkt nix damit zu tun hat
noch mal eine zweite runde an beraumt mit leuten die das jetzt endlich in ordnung bringen können dass denn eben die anwendung gefixt wird und wir in sieben tagen nicht komplett am arsch sind hätte er das nicht zufällig gemacht wäre das ganze im arsch gewesen
also das sind so sachen wo ich mir so denke wie kann es sein dass wir seit jahren angeblich solche dinger uns neue super agile und und durchdachte prozesse ausdenken und dann sowas passieren kann dass es einfach durch gut glück noch mal abgewendet wird
obwohl ich es gesagt habe in dem meeting das verstehe ich nicht also das ist komplett unmöglich in meiner welt normalerweise ja das ist weil dann muss man wirklich echt mal so weit gehen und sagen okay an der stelle hat eigentlich der manager seinen job nicht gemacht weil dafür ist er da sowas zu koordinieren
in dieser zweiten runde was witzig war in dieser zweiten runde war noch ein kollege von mir drinnen und dann wollten irgendwelche anwendungs entwickler dem aufschwätzen dass der sich jetzt darum kümmert dass das gefixt wird also die meinten damit also die wollten ihre anwendung nicht fixen die haben gesagt können wir nicht einfach wieder ein neues zertifikat beantragen von der alten zertifizierungsstelle
das ist so ein bullshit gefixe beim nächsten halben jahr ist es wieder kaputt da wird so viele leute ihr könnt euch gar nicht vorstellen wie viel im business enterprise umfeld gefrickelt wird das ist unglaublich das schlimme ist dass sie es nicht wahr haben wollen dass gefrickelt wird ohne ende aber dann immer so getan wird als wäre das alles die hohe kunst
dabei ist es einfach nur glück und gefrickelt zum größten teil dass der scheiß überhaupt funktioniert aber man verkauft es als super krasse fife header geschichte
und das ist bei google und facebook leute ich garantiere euch das das ist bei google fest ist es bei allen nicht anders die kochen alle nur mit wasser das ist vielleicht weniger schlimm ja da gehe ich von aus also ich klar ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass google facebook
oder sogar die telekom oder sowas sich in diesem ausmaß leisten könnten so ein bullshit zu machen wie wir aber in maßen ist das überall so
ja das beste start ups lass mich raten du bekommst doch das ganze geld oder
in welcher sprache würdest du eine robuste backup und archiv lösung programmieren willst du eine schon bestehende archiv lösung einfach nur automatisieren also hast du was was die backups macht und du möchtest das einfach nur automatisieren
oder möchtest du wirklich selbst eine backup und archiv lösung programmieren also da kommt es weniger auf die sprache an da kommt es eher auf dein know how an ob du überhaupt in der lage bist eine ordentliche
backup und archiv lösung zu programmieren das stelle ich mir nicht nicht ohne vor ich meine da archiv und erst dann kann jeder machen ja aber ok du willst damit rum basteln ganz ehrlich ich würde sowas in dort net machen weil dort net mein lieblings framework ist und sie scharpe meine lieblingssprache das kannst du in jeder sprache machen
vielleicht jetzt nicht gerade in kobol kannst du es in go machen kannst du es in dort net machen kannst du es in python machen kannst du es in ruby machen meine welche auch in c++ wobei ich davon abraten würde kannst du es in du kannst es eigentlich in alle machen kannst du es in java machen
bork ist cool kopia ist auch cool gib mal gute backups an also kannst du eigentlich alle möglichen das ist jetzt eigentlich ziemlich egal nimm die sprache die dir am besten gefällt
ok
ich brauche youtube premium ja zum beispiel leute die die offizielle app benutzen wollen ohne werbung und background play leider ist es so dass sowas mittlerweile premium features sind wobei man ja eigentlich sagen müssen sollte selbstverständlich sein
das muss ich öfters machen ich weiß nicht mehr ob was sich das bezogen hat
hast du mal probleme mit deinem arbeitgeber in deinem job ja man hat immer mal probleme gehabt also mit dem beim provider davor da hatte ich ja so probleme das ich gekündigt habe am aktuellen job hatte ich hatte ich auch mal probleme zum beispiel als ich teilzeit arbeiten wollte als ich das zum ersten mal gesagt habe muss ich zum betriebsrat
weil mein damaliger chef das überhaupt nicht richtig verkauft hat zumal ich der erste war der das der das machen wollte und da gab es probleme da muss ich zum betriebsrat und das war ein größerer akt aber dann ging es dann ging es doch ohne probleme weil sie wahrscheinlich auch wussten
können eigentlich gar nichts dagegen machen so wirklich ja also du musst deinem chef sagen was du für geilen mehrwert für die firma lieferst und wenn er keine ahnung von IT hat kannst du ihm sonst was erzählen
aber ein bisschen überprüfbar sollte es vielleicht schon sein als mannteilzeit warum nicht was hat es denn jetzt außerdem woher willst du wissen dass ich ein mann bin nicht dass wir gleich 30.000 leute haben die mega triggert sind auf twitter wenn ich das jetzt öffentlich poste
das kannst du doch gar nicht wissen ich war nur weil ich mich so anhöre ist jetzt 2022 nur wirklich kein indikator mehr dafür servus luigi danke für den sub
ok nice ich habe es geschafft leute 22 33 ich muss jetzt wirklich dringend ins bettge bettgetime ich hoffe euch hat das stream gefallen das war heute wieder mal ein üblicher
ich schwätze eineinhalb zweieinhalb stunden über gott und die welt und alles mögliche aber schön dass trotzdem so viele dabei waren wir sehen uns im nächsten stream bis denn macht's gut